we got some really big news pertaining
to foreign policy but first right before
we were about to go live as we're
getting set up for the show we got word
that Nick ricada ricada Law's Channel on
YouTube was totally nuked is completely
gone he was previously removed from
Twitter so I just want to say I'm
calling BS I don't know exactly what
happened but uh they're saying he
violated the YouTube terms of service
Community guidelines or whatever and uh
I don't know exactly why but I'm call I
think it's Mass flagging apparently
people are trying to they were
complaining about him trying to get him
disbarred so we'll learn more about that
as time goes on but Nick's Nick's a cool
dude he uh he does excellent legal
commentary so I just want to shout this
out because I'm calling BS on this I
don't think it's legitimate and my
immediate assumption though I haven't
it's it you know this is just happening
right now my assumption is mass flagging
resulted in an algorithmic takedown of
his channel so we'll see and we'll we'll
look more into this as The Show Goes On
but today my friends we got big news
because you Ryan has begun their Evac
preparations for a nuclear strike from
Russia they've been giving out potassium
iodide tablets Poland has asked the US
for nuclear weapons that sounds like a
really bad idea and uh this is the big
news OPEC is siding with Russia Joe
Biden is floundering they are cutting
down oil production which means gas
prices are going to Skyrocket they've
already been going up and this will
allow Russia to keep selling at a
discount they're selling to China China
is shipping it back to Europe they are
basically just
taking you up for a ride and the us is
going along with it so this is this is
absolutely brutal and it does feel like
we're headed towards World War III
we're gonna get into all that my friends
but before we do actually I was looking
at here we go head over to Virtua I'm
sorry surfinginternetsafe.com
and sign up for virtual Shield download
your virtual private network service a
VPN provided by virtual Shield a virtual
private Network helps keep you safe as
you browse the internet it's a basic
layer of security so if you're worried
about governments corporations or just
all around bad people spying on your
activity this is a basic layer of
protection the way I usually describe it
we don't expect anybody to break into
our house we still lock our doors and
window Windows hopefully have more than
one but again go to
surfinginternetsafe.com you can get
started with virtual Shield their their
VPN service is compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely securely securely and anonymously
using their Global Network of servers
and IPS when using their VPN service
your traffic gets routed through their
secure and encrypted servers that means
any restrictions censorship or blocks on
your internet are bypassed it is fast
and reliable all you got to do is
download it click one button go you're
good it runs it's available on Mac
Windows iPhone iPad Android or Chrome
does all the work for you it even
encrypts your Wi-Fi connection so for
from your device to your Wi-Fi router
they've got personal family and business
plans available family plan includes 15
devices the business plan allows you to
add as many employees as you need
virtual Shield has been sponsoring my
other show and and a timcast IRL they're
the first sponsor I ever got so I am I
am honored to continue working with them
these are the kind of companies you all
need to support because well they
support the work we're doing and they
make it all possible so again go to
surfinginternetsafe.com download Virtual
Shield also head over to timcast.com
become a member today I can only imagine
our members only show is going to be
pretty wild it's going to be a whole lot
of fun and we're going to talk about a
lot of crazy just just crazy things so
uh smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and again become a member
at timcast.com the reason I say the
after show is gonna get spicy is because
joining us today to talk about so much
is Jason burmes Tim thank you so much
for having me and I really do uh look
forward to the after show but this show
as well I mean like you said breaking
news is happening all the time and you
really are at the Forefront of the
Zeitgeist of what's going on culturally
on the internet I mean that's one of the
strong points of Tim cast IRL and I love
what you guys do here so uh who are you
what do you do
geez what do I do um some people know me
entry filmmaker other people know me as
a talk radio guy or someone that runs
his mouth on the internet I like to
think I'm kind of a slab of all those
things and really I'm just somebody who
wants the truth I think you know I'm not
about right or left I've always been
about right or wrong I've known this
gentleman to the left of me Lou
gradowski for some time and uh that
would probably be about the activist
portion of my life but look I'm just one
of those guys that doesn't like to be
lied to I don't want to be treated like
a child I think that our constitution
our Bill of Rights is really at the Apex
of what we should be trying to achieve
as a society I think it's the Perfectly
Imperfect document and unfortunately I
think
America has moved into an executive
within an executive where that no longer
pertains almost at all there are no
checks and balances it's not the
judicial executive and legislative
anymore and it's moved into this
authoritarian style of government aided
by big Tech with media narrative
management so I'll just say this very
very quickly before we move on there's a
documentary that I'm sure most people
watching this have seen of which you are
associated with going way back in the
day I was working at O'Hare Airport some
guy walks in with a DVD or was that
probably a CD at that time and he's like
you gotta watch this and then we all
watched a loose change
yeah so loose change is the big one man
it's kind of where we took the internet
and we utilized it to empower Humanity
with information that was not being
given by the mainstream and now we see
restrictions on those same platforms
because really without Google video
um tried to compete with YouTube and
absorbing it would that movie as been as
big as it possibly was I mean you got
CDs and there's ground work there people
like Lou gradowski and myself burning
discs handing them out to people in fact
when we were selling the movie one of
the things we encourage people to do
don't buy one copy get the spindles sure
they don't come in a case but they were
super cheap you get them at 10 25 even
100 and people would do that I think the
hundred ones you could get for two
dollars a disc so it was like 50 bucks
and then you could hand somebody that
disc and they would watch it we'll get
into that in a whole bunch probably in
the members show because that there's a
lot to talk about we were talking before
the show or I should say you are telling
us about a whole bunch of crazy stuff
it's gonna be fun
check 100 discs at two dollars each
would be 200 not 50. oh I'm seeing you
got me you got it all right so that's
gonna be it's gonna be fun thanks for
coming and of course uh Luke's here the
Burmese Boomer Brigade is here oh yeah
thank you so much for coming on Jason
I've known Jason for 16 years I think in
one day we gave out what was it 10 000.
on the fifth anniversary in in New York
City with a mortal technique Alex Jones
we had a crazy event down there that you
guys were a part of so uh really happy
to see you here the shirt I'm wearing
right now reads that the truth is the
first casualty of War I think that is
definitely the truth right now when it
comes to geopolitics if you like the
shirt you could get it on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com because you do
this is why I'm here thank you so much
again for having me and uh super excited
to have you on yeah in the first last 30
minutes we did basically transhumanist
boot camp Jason I have 21 tabs open from
xenotransplantation to what's the
signature reduction to Blackjack
satellite missions good conversation man
I'm looking forward to going deeper on
all these things pumped yeah Jason got
here early and I was delighted to be
able to talk to him about all this stuff
and I was like yo we're not gonna be
able to talk about any of the stuff on
the Regular Show so the after Show's
gonna be lit you guys gotta make sure
your members for sure let's get into it
all right let's jump into this first
story from the hill Ukraine Capital
preparing evacuation centers for
possible Nuclear Strike they're also
handing out potassium iodide Poland's
been doing the same thing and the other
big news here is that Poland suggests
hosting U.S nuclear weapons amid growing
fears of Putin's threats so look all of
this
you know when I see Ukraine and they're
they're giving out potassium iodide
these are the tablets you take to try
and protect your thyroid when there's
radioactive particles everywhere and
they're prepping evacuation centers I
don't trust Ukraine look I don't like
that Russia invaded them I don't like
that Russia is annexing these regions I
don't like any of that stuff I don't
like what they do with Crimea but I
think Ukraine is desperate so they're
going to say whatever they need to say
to make it seem like the end is not and
we need to keep giving them money and
they just announced what another like
600 million dollars 625 or some
ridiculous number so when Ukraine's like
oh you prepare for a nuclear strike are
they doing that to freak us out to get
the headline or are they actually
concerned it's going to happen that
being said when Poland suggests hosting
U.S nuclear weapons which is basically
spitting in the face of Putin who said
do not move nukes into Eastern Europe
maybe it's not so much that they're
watching in Ukraine they're watching
Putin do something although that train
carrying like the nuclear mod Group
whatever was called they are saying that
but maybe the reason Ukraine is prepping
for a nuclear strike is because they
know what NATO is doing and they know
what NATO is doing will result in a
response from Vladimir Putin yeah I mean
let's be honest here if you're not
worried you're not paying attention to
what's going on here there's been severe
escalations on both sides this is headed
down down a trajectory of just further
uh dangerous Pathways that of course
don't have any diplomacies don't have
any dip to taunt don't have any
compromises the only reason why the
world wasn't blown up during the Cold
War is because people negotiated people
came to the negotiation table and said
okay let's figure this out let's make
sure we compromise on a deal that
benefits both of us so we could both get
away from killing each other and and
extinguishing and destroying the entire
world we're not having any of that the
president of Ukraine literally just
signed into law a decree that prevents
him from even negotiating with Vladimir
Putin and and having a peace deal with
him that that to me is absolutely absurd
and it's it is crazy yeah they frame
Kennedy as having just strong strong man
who was the Russian Premier at the time
it was Khrushchev to take take the nukes
out of Cuba and Khrushchev did it but
that's not what happened Kennedy used
diplomacy and he worked with khrush Jeff
and said we'll take our nukes out of
turkey if you take your nukes out of
Cuba it was a diplomatic action and
without diplomacy we're not going to see
the nukes we're not going to see the
escalation this is Will Chamberlain
brought this up well you're specifically
talking about the Cuban Missile Crisis
where not many people know this and
people didn't know this when it was
happening but as you mentioned JFK
compromised with Khrushchev and JFK
agreed to get rid of the missiles that
were located in Italy and in turkey that
Russia thought was going to be used
against them and therefore the Russians
were then only willing to compromise and
get rid of their missiles from Cuba
which of course threatened the United
States so that was a compromise hold on
how could JFK have done that surely the
information on where those nukes were
were classified and he wouldn't have the
authority to declassify any of
information like that right some some
greater Authority than the president I
mean that right am I wrong because it
turns out the president can declassify
the 1960s were different than 2022 well
the whole thing with Trump and the and
the classified documents just shows
maybe the country has been subjugated if
the president is now being attacked
because he had classified documents when
previously we had a President Who
revealed the location of our nuclear
weapons directly to our principal
adversary and that was a good thing
now Trump can't even have documents that
were empty folders apparently it just
goes to show that the presidency is
subjugated by something yeah what you
were saying earlier Jason you think
there's some sort of authoritarian
aspect here I'm looking I just got a
tweet from disclose.tv that the U.S is
to buy quote nuclear emergency drugs for
290 million dollars from a part of
pharmaceutical company uh what is this
called Amgen is the name of the company
it's called n plate is the health and
human services drug 125 micrograms is
around twelve hundred dollars so don't
discount the pharmaceutical companies
attempt to profit off of a nuclear scare
oh man look potassium iodide is just
like it's cheap it's just it's nothing
it's potassium it's iodine you can get
iodine from your table salt you get that
you know I I what is it like iodine salt
or whatever you get a little Morton girl
with the umbrella or whatever that works
too the point of these pills is that it
Associates your thyroid it gives you all
the potenti all the iodine you need so
you don't absorb the particles but I'm
saying
I would not be surprised if these
companies come up with some way to make
something slightly different you know
what they add they'll add a little
aspirin to it and be like it'll protect
you from radiation and cure a headache
and it costs a thousand dollars that's
exactly what they're doing this is from
healthandhumanservices.gov HHS purchases
drug for use in radiological and nuclear
emergencies and they're going right to a
private pharmaceutical does it say what
the what the drug is uh yeah I think I
just mentioned it as an end plate
n-p-l-a-t-e I'd have to I'd have to look
into what that does sure it's a
subcutaneous uh subcutaneous powder for
injection according to Disclose TV then
they link us over to Health and Human
Services where they get the information
well I don't know man but do you guys
even think it's going to get to that
point I I kind of feel like everything
we've seen so far is is indicative of
escalation let me just say this the
rhetoric is very dangerous right so we
could go back a few months ago where you
had the head of the Russian space
division saying they could nuke all NATO
Nations within 30 minutes not great I'm
not very happy about that that's
something that was put out there you
have David Petraeus this week on CNN
discussing if the Russians were to use a
nuclear strike that we would basically
be able to use our military to take out
their entire Seaboard it's like not even
the Black Sea Fleet exactly
um how horrible that would be so the
language that's being used the things
that are being portrayed to the public
you talked about the iodine thing well
how about that New York City emergency
uh PSA where they're just talking about
a random nuclear weapon going off in the
city and what should we don't know why
we don't know how it's not important
we've never talked like this at least
not since the 80s you were saying the US
did buy these these drugs yeah they're
ordering it right now as part of the
long-standing effort uh was this
so I I just you just check check this
out it's uh if you want to look it up
it's aspr aspr but if you look up what's
the website or what's the what's the
title I can go HHS purchases drug for
use in radiological and nuclear
emergencies
what do we got is that from Bloomberg no
it's from hhs.gov whoa
yo age of just buying 290 million
dollars worth of Amgen drug and plate
for radiation sickness in nuclear
emergency whenever that's tax money
being spent well obviously well yeah
yeah
it's called theft Ian so look here's
what I want to say sometimes they tell
you exactly what they're doing and
what's coming I mean if they're doing
this they're not keeping it a secret
from us that they think we're going to
nuclear war no it's dangerous and it's
it's not just Petraeus it seems like
everybody who supposedly is an
authoritative Source on this in our
military and on the media is saying that
tactical Nuclear strikes might be okay
this is insane you know you know what
really really pisses me off right now is
that this this company that's on this
drug didn't call it rat away
yeah really yeah they're missing the
market maybe they would have gotten sued
by by Bethesda shut up a Fallout this is
saying that let's call it right away the
biomedical Advanced research and
development Authority in 2004 uh got
some new Authority called project
bioshield act and can now I don't know
spend indiscriminately I don't know what
it can do with this project bioshield
act signed in 2004 sounds like a bush
thing probably afraid of you know there
was all this weapons of mass destruction
fear so they're like we gotta sign new
authoritarian laws to give us over
arcing uh authority to do whatever we
want so this is a treatment for acute
radiation sickness due to a radiological
or nuclear emergency and it is approved
for immune thrombocytopenia a blood
disorder characterized by a low platelet
count by low platelet counts plural so
um
maybe they're just like here's an
opportunity to give money to the
pharmaceutical companies or maybe
they're like
there's going to be a nuclear war
Putin's going to do it
here's the thing let's say a nuclear
bomb goes off anywhere in the world we
live in such a post-truth world that how
do you attribute that to anybody because
you know who the media is going to oh
dude look at nordstream exactly not only
that but the United States also on
record Lost nuclear weapons that they
can't account for and guess what the
Russians lost a lot more of them as well
especially when the Soviet Union
collapsed literally people walked into
military facilities it was like yeah
I'll give you a thousand rubles for that
and they're like yeah here here's your
nuclear weapon so there's a lot of
nuclear weapons that are out there
um that that we can't account for that
we don't know where they are they could
be in private hands they could be in
very Sinister hands they could be in
third parties that could profit off of
escalating this conflict and as we
talked about before maybe it's not even
the United States responsible for this
gas explosion maybe it's a private
industrial complex company organization
party or even third party like China
that's sitting back and saying well
maybe we could watch these two countries
fight each other and then grow in the
absence of of them obliterating each
each other what if there was like a
former special agent from like the UK
was like MI6 is that what it's called
MI6 yeah and then and what he did was he
got a bunch of other special agents to
come work for him and was like a rogue
Nation
well we got to understand we're living
in a place where multinational
corporations have a lot more power and
influence than governments we we have to
understand Biden right here is not
making not making any decisions he's not
calling the shots here he is someone
that is not of sound mind he can't make
coherent sentences there's no way he
could be handling the most stressful job
as described by many presidents of the
United States to be in that Oval Office
there's no way he is working non-stop
there's no way he's cutting deals
negotiating behind the closed doors
there's someone else calling the shots
here who is that person well I think
it's the people benefiting uh off of a
lot of his failed policies that destroy
the American lower and middle class and
of course prop up the billionaires the
bankers and of course the private
interests that I think are truly calling
the shots here who are uh you know
Psychopathic who will do anything to get
money to get power to get influence and
I think a lot of them are even satanic
but that's the whole different
perspective I don't even want to go down
there the the issue is
don't think about it in terms of the
NATO versus Russia think about it in
terms of something you believe is is
right and something you see someone
doing that you believe is wrong and then
think about your willingness to allow
them to keep doing it to to prevent a
fight this is what this is the think
about a a a a a child drag show you know
most people probably do not want to see
those things
but when we have people going out and
protesting fights happen so this is the
problem we don't want the fighting but I
want you know people will you'll
understand the perspective of what what
NATO and what Russia are both feeling
they're both saying we will not stop
they're both saying if you want to avoid
war you back down and they're both
saying that exactly to each other
because they both think they're right I
don't think
for the most part A lot of these NATO
countries I think a lot of the people in
these countries think they're
legitimately correct and right I think
they're evil a lot of them I think their
attitude is elitist and the people are
stupid and we're better than them but
we're doing the right thing and they
should be grateful and I think Putin's
probably the exact same way but just not
aligned with them and so they're adamant
that they are deserving of their their
Quest towards their ideology and no one
is going to back down there's no
scenario I see Vladimir Putin being like
well NATO's expanding on my border
whatever Russia can Russia can just roll
over no way dude's gonna be like I want
to bring back the Soviet Union it was a
travesty that I mean he literally said
this and it's a travesty that that
collapse and our leaders let us down
this is not a guy who's going to be like
it's a good thing that Western forces
are taking over our country he thinks
it's a horrible thing Constantine
kissing translated his speech which
everyone should check out on Twitter
it's a long thread and Putin was
essentially intimating that the liberal
economic order's gone too far as
destroying Earth it's creating you know
it's satanic I think he even said at one
point and he will it's going it's
falling and he won't it's he's going to
make sure that it falls right he said
the Satanism thing in line with the
gender Idol ideology that's going to be
pushed and I actually watched uh
leninoff at the un uh in the previous
week and it was hard for me to just no
roosophile right I agree with you Tim
that Putin's not a great guy he's got
his mindset he has Authority
authoritarianism but when you have
leninoff sitting there talking about the
war on terror what we did in Afghanistan
Iraq Libya Somalia and Beyond it's hard
to argue with the guy what Freedom did
we bring you know are these
nation-states better off after our
intervention or are they worse off well
I think by any measure of the
imagination most of these plea most
these places have become even more
failed States they have slavery in Libya
for God's sakes I mean it's 2022 and
would that have happened without U.S
military intervention I doubt it you
know so so it's tough because their
rhetoric sounds pretty good right now
but then you have people biting on that
line that somehow you know Putin's the
good guy and he's fighting these people
I think that they're all fighting for
their vision of what globalism is going
to become in The Next Century and all
any regular person wants is to go into
their yard throw some feed to their
chickens collect some eggs Bring
breakfast to their family and then mind
their own business that's but
unfortunately there are ideologues and
there are zealots who are hell-bent on
controlling your life and some of them
amass tons of power and they want to
blow up kids take over your country and
take away your chickens and they amass
nuclear weapons which endanger the
entire world and then as Burma's pointed
out something that I've been saying from
the very beginning of this conflict
everyone's looking out for themselves uh
Putin is looking out for Putin he's
looking out also for his country his
interests the United States is looking
out for their interests and there's no
denying it especially with the moves
that have been made here but when do we
make a stop when do we like try to pause
this Insanity that has led us to this
situation where young men and and
innocent human beings are dying for the
political Ambitions of politicians that
to me is absurd I gotta pull up this
story from the New York Times because
boy you want to talk about World War III
the New York Times reports the U.S
believes ukrainians were behind an
assassination in Russia just say in the
headline the assassination of Daria
dugina American officials said they were
not aware of the plan ahead of time for
the attack that killed Daria dugina and
that they had admonished Ukraine over it
oh admonished
so what do you think Russia is going to
say to that that's it's War right
they're not even Russia's not even
calling this a war yet what do you think
the people I mean this is the kind of
thing with with U.S admission now that
will boost morale among Russians so do
you see the uh clip of Jeffrey Sachs on
Bloomberg recently that's gone kind of
viral where he is basically saying hey
the rest of the world the Optics on this
is the U.S blew up this Nordstrom
Pipeline and actually this conflict is a
proxy war between the United States and
Russia he's like that's how everybody
else and they were like whoa well hold
on there we'll hold I don't know about
that exactly well I've actually so the
two-minute clip that's going around on
Twitter there's an eight minute clip and
Jeffrey sacks Nails it throughout I
actually covered it yesterday but that's
the thing the rest of the world already
understands the narrative is the United
States is in a full-on proxy war with
Russia we're not even acknowledging that
I mean it's not it's not a proxy war
it's War NATO is is in Poland the Supply
Military supplies are being delivered to
Ukraine and it's so obvious that NATO is
now now worried Russia will strike
Poland because that's where they're
delivering the weapons so it's like the
way I describe it let's say there's a
dude throwing rocks at you and you're
like bro stop throwing rocks at me and
behind him is another guy handing him
rocks are we gonna be alike the guy
handing him rocks has nothing to do with
this and we're not fighting no both of
them are at war with you so it's not a
proxy war we've got American citizens
and NATO citizens on the ground in
Ukraine and they're going we're just
volunteers oh spare me dude NATO is
delivering weapons tanks they just said
a bunch of Apache helicopters to Poland
Poland now wants nukes and then those
weapons are being delivered to American
veterans who are fighting as mercenaries
for Ukraine that's a technicality I
don't think Vladimir Putin is looking at
that and going well he's not formally
working for the U.S no he's just armed
by them a citizen of the country and
benefits from it and fighting for a
country that is being massively funded
the tune of billions of dollars by the
US come on Putin's not some [ __ ] who's
like looking over a legal document being
like well I would declare war on NATO
but they found all the loopholes they're
able to go to war with us but it's not
formal so what am I supposed similar to
Vietnam where the Chinese were sending
the North Vietnamese all sorts of
weapons and tanks and but we didn't
strike China because or Russia I think
the Russians were involved with
spreading it to North North Korea or
North Vietnam too um because it's but
it's really the military contractors are
profiting off of limited War they don't
want a total war they don't want Russia
to attack Poland they don't want the U.S
to drop bombs in Moscow they want to
just keep selling weapons to the front
to these poor ukrainians who are in this
flat terrain that are just getting
artillery shelled and and then they keep
profiting it's a really War for profit I
think and a small amount of land that
Putin wants to connect to Crimea
well the Tim's point on the proxy
um Michael Tracy who I follow on Twitter
I think he does some really good work is
outright saying that U.S soldiers are in
command and control of the ground
Warfare there of course come on but I
would take it a step further and say
well our starlink systems are arming The
Ghost and Sidewinder drones that are
killing Russian soldiers the
concentration of starlink there is 12
000 is the greatest concentration on the
planet I would say that's overt Warfare
and the U.S provided the intelligence
used by the ukrainians who use NATO
weapons to blow up the flagship of of
Putin's or Russia's uh Black Sea uh
Fleet so uh like come on yeah World War
II the U.S was selling weapons to
England for a layer is giving them lend
lease they weren't even charging them
and the Germans knew but the Germans
like well this sucks we can't declare
war on America because that will lose
the war but then eventually when after
the United States made that argument
actually that he lost 80 million dollars
on their latest satellite launches into
the Ukraine you know he put out that
poll on you know that solution but if
you follow that thread he says look we
actually lost money sending these
starlink satellites out there so he's
admitting that they're being used in
Warfare but he wants to kind of paint
the picture it's just for communications
for the good guys but again they're
hooking up to drones that are taking
real lives you know that's real Warfare
in my opinion and uh you know Eric
Schmidt the former CEO of Google came
out and called Elon Musk the true hero
of the Ukrainian war and now Elon Musk
is being labeled a traitor to the
Ukrainian people which is absolutely
totally absurd and it's not just
satellite uh Internet it's also
satellite images it's also GPS tracking
it's also troop movements that the
United States is advising the Ukrainian
troops saying hey we're going to say
we're going to kerasan but really we're
going to Lyman and then now we're going
to fake Lyman now we're going to kirison
because this is how the troops are
moving in this specific region this is
the weak spots that we see here and with
the the the the Weaponry that they have
the advanced technology today I saw a
video of a Ukrainian using a our own
denial weapon against a Russian DGI
mavic drone that was flying over getting
reconnaissance and a Russian soldier had
this huge uh you know gun that was
provided to him by the West very
literally Soldier Ukrainian Ukrainian
shoulder had this huge gun that that
pointed at the Drone and just took it
down right away did they reuse it did
they recover it and then use it probably
yeah you know because the Russians a lot
of them are buying you know dgis off of
the private market and literally using
them for reconnaissance meanwhile the
United States is using satellite imagery
to you know get all the information
about where where they are the exact GPS
coordinates the coordinates are put into
the starlink satellites connected to the
weaponries the weapons and the missiles
just fly directly on top of the Russians
you know that there are psychotic nerds
that are just like tracking the data
analytics and like oh this is how people
act when they're think they're at War
and Afraid how what if we turn up the
fear oh this is how they act oh they
send weapons oh they tend to go further
south where it's warmer when they're
afraid oh you know like weird crazy the
psychopathic scientists that are like
pushing it but today also very
interestingly it's it's it's very
captivating to see technology play such
an active role in this uh a proxy war
between the East and the West because
also very interestingly the Ukrainian
government also expelled Iranian
diplomats from their country
specifically because Iran provided
suicide drones to the Russians that they
have allegedly used today on a military
uh Camp inside of Kiev so there's big
news today that Iranian drone struck
inside of Kiev uh and that was
specifically why ukrainians expelled
Iranian uh diplomats
suicide drone was it like strapped to
the bomb or something it was just it's
just a drone that flies up and then when
it when it lands it explodes so this is
something you mentioned earlier Business
Insider Russia's space agency Chief
claimed his Nation could destroy NATO
countries in half an hour during a
nuclear war so uh highlighting this when
you have the us being like Oh Ukraine
just assassinated the daughter a
prominent reporter and the daughter of a
prominent uh influencer or whatever you
want to call him philosopher in Russia
and we're we're just going along with
what they're doing they are going to
drag us into a war where they're they
they are
capable of and directly threatening to
wipe out the entirety of the of NATO
which includes us I would much prefer
not to be nuked because I've grown quite
fond of living so uh for everybody else
maybe we can tell Ukraine to knock off
this kind of insanity if you want to
defend your land because Russia's
invading totally get it going into
Russia and killing some dude's daughter
and a prominent journalist hey maybe
that's a big big mistake
well there are War when you're at War
there's no nothing's off the top that's
true this idea that you know I'm writing
these articles and they're like Putin's
illegal Invasion I'm like oh I'm sure
Putin cares about what you think is
legal yeah it's it's it really is insane
that we have these concepts of like war
crimes now I get it to a certain degree
we're like we're gonna try and stop
these things from happening and create
some kind of framework for if you do it
there will be severe penalties when we
defeat you but it's like at the same
time yo if somebody is fighting against
you to with the intent to kill you
they're gonna do anything and everything
your laws are meaningless there's that
gentleman War where if you're fighting
the enemy you know you want to capture
their commander and then sell them back
rather than kill them you don't want to
kill everybody you want you want to
profit off the war that's the point of
the war is you want to come up better
afterwards so right but if we're talking
about existential conflict when we're
talking about like you know with the
colonial wars it was like over territory
and new lands and things like that then
they're gonna be like okay fine you can
take that territory oh we've lost Quebec
you know whatever
but what we're talking about here is
Putin thinking or saying that well he
says he would use nuclear weapons if
there's an existential threat to Russia
NATO encroaching on its borders and
cutting off its ability to sell fuel
into Europe is probably an existential
threat to Russia this is not Russia's
interests overseas this is their actual
border being threatened so I don't think
they're going to play any games where
they're alike we'll capture them and
sell them back no they're going to be
like destroy them
maybe but I don't think that they want
the Russia to get nuked like if Russia
if nukes drop all over Russia Russian
cities they lose so
I think of nuke struck it's mutually
assured destruction I can't believe
people aren't talking more about that
you don't think so huh you think that we
can have kind of these tactical Nuclear
Wars where only certain areas are hit
and it doesn't just set off that Chain
Reaction yep
so tactical news first we'll start with
tactical news being much lower yield
we're not talking about an ICBM wiping
out a million people we're talking about
ten thousand to a hundred thousand
depending on the yield of the Tactical
nuke really really bad but there was a
great quote I can't remember who who
just said it recently they said if Putin
nukes a issues a nuclear strike on a
NATO Nation there will not be a nuclear
response because the American president
would have to be insane to sacrifice
Boston for posnan so if Putin were to
Nuke that the us is going to be like if
we respond they'll respond again and
then we will actually get hit ourselves
in our homeland and be forced to defend
ourselves here if the fighting stays
over there they'll probably respond with
full-scale conventional Warfare not a
nuclear strike there's no reason for
Putin right now to just be like I'm
gonna Nuke DC now if you if you fired a
nuke at DC yeah maybe we would fire a
nuke back at Moscow or something and
that's the deterrent don't do it because
we'll do it back we'd find like 100
nukes back at my like 30 at Moscow 30 at
Novus beers you know all over the spot
all over the place
if Putin is using nuclear artillery and
tactical nukes in Ukraine ain't nobody
gonna respond if they drop 100 kiloton
bomb on Kiev and kill 20 30 000 people
NATO will not nuke back that that's
because Ukraine is not a NATO nation and
no NATO nation is going to sacrifice
their capital for anything in Ukraine
right now they're content with sending
supplies and having them fight they
don't want Russia to win but I don't see
you know Poland's asking for nukes I
don't see Poland sacrificing poznan for
Kiev
Kiev to get hit and they're going to be
like we don't want to get hit next so we
got to keep we're not going to respond
in kind not only that but they can't
even respond if they wanted to they have
no nukes I guess my greatest fear is if
any kind of nuclear strike happens
anywhere our world changes overnight and
it just gives you this excuse to roll
out all sorts of Martial law slash
authoritarian measures wherever you know
it wouldn't matter which side it was on
like if like say that happens say 10 000
people get taken out and attack attack
tactical strike in the Ukraine you don't
think that this Administration here
would utilize that not only to instill
fear on the American public
um but pass certain executive orders and
measures that would restrict yeah I mean
that's directive 51 you guys know
directive 51 man about it you ever play
the game the division no I never played
oh come on that game's great was there a
bush uh directive Bush director nine
after nine and we it was I think it was
in like 2007 we're not sure if it's
legal it's never been tested but
presidential National Security
Presidential Directive 51 allows the
president to basically overwrite the US
government and create a new one yeah
that was George Bush George Bush and I
believe Obama revised it since since
then it's gone through several changes
many people have said it's a nonsense
executive order because the executive
branch doesn't have the authority to
overthrow the US government because of
an emergency but the language of it is
nuts it basically says if any kind of
disaster happens anywhere the president
of the United States can declare an
enduring constitutional government and
install a continuity coordinator who now
runs all of the branches and it creates
one branch that controls everything this
would be quote any incident regardless
of location that results in
extraordinary levels of mass casualties
damage or disruption severely affecting
the US population infrastructure
environment economy or government
functions disruption severely affecting
the U.S population so like what a
hurricane a storm a blackout yes yeah
exactly so it's not been tested many
people think that if they tried to do it
there'd be challenges the problem is in
a circumstance where they do declare I
think it's been updated and there's a
different executive order on the books
now but in the event that something
happens like a nuke does drop on Kiev
I really doubt there's going to be it's
going to no one in the United States is
going to be able to do anything about it
if they do it because it would just be
civil war
you're going to get people who are going
to be like dude a nuke was dropped I
ain't going I'm I'm not I'm not I'm not
standing up I'm not
do whatever right most people will
probably say I'm scared of nukes so when
the government says we're at War and
this is the way it is they'll just say
okay I'm concerned of false Flags here
because anybody could drop a nuke
anywhere well that's my point if a nuke
goes up no one knows who actually did it
you know who they'll blame right
regardless Russia is going to get blamed
I've been blaming Russia for everything
it's like some dudes like walking and
Democrat stubs his toe and he's like ah
Putin put that rock there and you know
Donald Trump wins an election and of
course it had to be Putin well they've
been laying down the groundwork for this
for many years now I mean the Cold War
essentially never ended it's only
escalating from here there were many
proxy wars even recently Syria was a
major proxy war between the East and the
West now that theater moved the the the
the conflict still continues in Syria
but that theater moved to Ukraine it's
expanding it's growing and for the last
few years the corporate media with the
intelligence agencies have been laying
down the groundwork Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia non-stop even when there
was is reasons not to criticize him
there's a lot of things you can
criticize about Russia there's a lot of
things that they did in Georgia in
Crimea that you could of course heavily
criticize with the you know destruction
of civil liberties and human rights in
their country sure there's a lot of
things you could do that but the
Intelligentsia here in the United States
made stuff up just to point the finger
and blame on Russia I think I know what
really happened
before all of this back in December
Putin had a secret meeting with Joe
Biden right and they were like hey
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
fake this war right you know why because
then Putin's like I'm gonna use nukes
and then you respond aliens reveal
themselves and shut down the nukes and
that's how we get them to come out of
hiding that proves it I'm kidding by the
way let's jump to this next story from
the telegram
if what they're doing is a Psy up and
they're trying to get me to beg for a
new world order it's starting to work
because any kind of order Global Order
would be well maybe not any but would be
better than a nuclear war I mean this is
the best way to do it you get Biden and
Putin you know firing nukes at each
other and then whoever you want to
actually run your new government comes
out and says people the war is bad it's
not working join me and we'll come up
we'll bring about a cryptocurrency yes
you know single currency for the planet
will end all of this trip in your in
your wrist and you will be immune to
nuclear fallout Central Bank digital
currency which the US Federal Reserve
and many other countries are putting
into practice that alien stuff there are
some uh very notable people that that do
believe aliens have prevented nuclear
war on this planet there are some right
that's what defense Ministers of Canada
yeah yeah no no I'm expanding on it
Jason's shaking his head here uh whether
you agree with them or disagree with
them this is the the bigger context to
what Tim is saying here all right check
out this story from the telegraph oil
cartel joins forces with Russia to cut
supplies congratulations ladies and
gentlemen because of the war in Ukraine
a gentle gentleman yes because of the
war in Ukraine that we are involved in
OPEC Saudi Arabia are joining with
Russia cutting production cranking up
prices so that Russia can keep selling
at a premium rate to China and then sell
it back to us so we are getting screwed
and funding this war
your costs are going to go up your
standard of living is going to go down
and it's because Joe Biden is a corrupt
piece of trash who keeps funneling our
money to Ukraine why do we why should I
care about Ukraine because because
Vladimir Putin's charging too much for
natural gas into Europe well too bad you
build your pipeline like they did the
Baltic pipe fine blowing up someone
else's pipeline expanding your military
Alliance all of this was pushing towards
War now Putin invaded Ukraine bad thing
I get it but I'm not going to sit here
and say the U.S should sacrifice its
people so that Ukraine can have so that
we can deal with their problem I just
here you go thanks Joe Biden let's see
if this impacts the midterms well if you
remember a couple months ago Joe Biden
had a very uh publicized trip to Saudi
Arabia where he was going to go to Saudi
Arabia and make sure that they produce
more energy and oil from the world since
of course it's very green to stop
domestic energy exploration and
production and of course depend on Saudi
Arabia and the Henry Kissinger supported
Petro dollar which again absolutely
mind-boggling but if you remember from
that trip he was like I'm gonna go there
I'm going to make sure we have a ton of
energy they're going to be pumping in
out of the ground and and there was even
a press release from the White House
saying this this trip was successful and
then the Saudi Arabians came out said no
it wasn't we're not going to be pumping
oil we're not doing that and now this is
on the heels of that meeting of Joe
Biden going down to Saudi Arabia and
essentially I do think the OPEC
countries the oil producing countries
are looking out for themselves because
they see this as an opportunity they
will be enriching themselves and I do
see other individuals that are going to
of course be also benefiting from an
energy crisis which is already here and
it's only going to get worse with this
latest news this to me is a longer part
of the agenda of the great reset which
is deliberately denying people energy to
stop human progress and enslave them we
just got a good Super Chat from just
political makes a good point nothing
will stop a midterm election faster than
emergency wartime powers
if Russia were a month out what if the
October surprise is that Putin drops a
nuke and they suspend elections what do
you mean Putin that's right so let's put
that in quotes because we don't know
yeah what happens
or something crazy like any kind of
conventional and they suspend election
saying we can't so it's an emergency and
the country's got to mobilize
that's what we are man he got a third
term during wartime they let him stay I
don't put anything past these people but
I think we also have to understand that
the infrastructure is still there that
allows for elections to be gamed I don't
think that we should have voting systems
in other words machines that are plugged
into anything that can be accessed by a
router that do fractional voting I don't
think we should have mail and voting I I
think the issue is Ian points out all
the time is the closed Source nature of
the machines but yeah because if the
code is private I really don't want to
segue the conversation off of what we
were talking about because my concern is
will there be a nuclear strike is there
going to be severe economic damage from
say uh oil prices skyrocketing what do
we see like nine bucks already in
California again like eight eight fifty
or something like that will that result
in some kind of emergency wartime powers
or the inverse says they can't shut the
election down it would destroy the
country gas prices are so high Democrats
get swept out of office I was going to
say to you okay Stacy Abrams but that's
beyond the point from the conversation
here but anyway it this will be
impacting the average American but more
significantly the people who don't have
money the people who are the poorest in
our country will now have a harder time
making ends meet paying for gas for your
car paying for heat this winter will
become more difficult not just for the
people in the United States but
specifically other people outside of the
United States who don't have it as as
lucky as we do people in Europe are
absolutely dealing with a huge energy
crisis where many businesses are already
shutting down their doors because they
can't find a way to pay for the energy
bill that's that's crazy your life
savings are going towards heating your
home right now in Europe and this is how
you're spending your money when of
course a lot of this is orchestrated by
Bad Decisions by politicians and Central
controllers that are artificially hiking
up the price of energy for their own
personal benefit because they know once
they create artificial scarcity they're
able to do what they want with the human
population and with the decline of
energy it also brings on the decline of
the food production it brings on the
decline of humanity
I think that you need an October
surprise right so you're talking about
all these price increases I think that
this is part of what the sustainability
movement really is and what
sustainability really means is your
standard of living is going to plummet
so this is further hurting anything
that's remnant of the middle class
they're lying about how much inflation
has gone on obviously it's more than
eight point whatever percent and if you
continue these Trends gradually you got
the country even further and you really
go into this Global idea set of scarcity
and we need a new system of control and
that's where you have your social credit
score that's where you have your carbon
credit system even the world economic
Forum I know we mentioned Iran they have
their world food program that they plan
on running through the blockchain they
have a whole little bit wow about
running uh refugee camps via blockchain
technology you guys seen uh you remember
Viva Vendetta when Natalie Portman is
eating the toast and she's like is this
real butter like I haven't had this was
a kid that's what they want for you and
your kids your kids are going to wake up
in the morning and they're you're going
to be laying next to them in your pod
they're going to open the pod and
they're going to be you know outside
surrounded by a whole bunch of other
pods and then the robot's gonna drive by
and hand your child a bowl of crickets
with what with floating in water and the
kid's gonna be spooning it and that's
that's breakfast cereal and then the
robot says and remember if you follow
all the rules and bend the knee you
might get a small piece of beef this
week
it true but I think it will be too
dangerous to give kids spoons because
you could use them as weapons so they'll
probably have them plastic
semi-conscious in a floating tank of
biological
harvesting their heat yeah they'll
you're locked in the Pod and the tube
just goes into your mouth The Crickets
just get poured if you're lucky
otherwise it's going in the other other
end
um I don't know why they wouldn't shoot
Cricket up your ass have you started to
liquefy them first uh have you studied
absorption what do you think they that
the overall idea of the transhumanist
desire for the human population is like
I I think that they want us in back to
tanks like in Star Trek or in Star Wars
where Luke has his hand cut off but
they're like floating him in that tank
but it's like regenerating his body
slowly but something that's
piezoelectric and can wear your body
just the heat vibrates
we really jumped overboard from and only
we don't have to stay on this topic yeah
nice digression there do you think they
want like people docile and tanks do you
think they want them working at jobs
what do you it's two different things
right so the transhumans agenda for
those that can afford it is you're going
to be able to remain in your biological
body and the advancements will allow you
to at least double your lifespan a lot
of these things people think that you
know Jared Kushner went on television
two weeks ago and said my generation is
either going to be the first to live
forever or the last to die now Jared
Kushner has billions of dollars to spend
on that the vast majority of us don't
the same people that are investing in
that technology via things like Calico
which is run by Kurzweil in his alphabet
or Google's company on immortality then
you have the people that want you to
merge with the machines and this is kind
of the digital human or mind clone
aspect of it so at one aspect the very
rich believe that they're going to be
able to stay in their biological body
but then they're going to try to
acclimate the rest of us to accept
things like neuralink human brain
interfaces and Beyond to the point where
they get the populace to believe that
they can actually upload their
Consciousness into a digital hellscape
in my opinion but this metaverse so
you're going to be spending so much time
in the metaverse anyway before the human
brain interfaces you're going to be
acclimated to these things and you're
going to hate reality especially if you
can't eat steak anymore and you can't
have a burger and you can't travel
because you can't afford your gas in
your car yeah like that dude in The
Matrix remember he's eating the steak
and he's like I don't care well first
before they do that they need to put the
human population on their knees and I do
believe this artificial scarcity this
energy crisis to bring it back to the
topic that we were discussing here is
the first step out of many steps in
order to make the general population
acquiesce by robbing people of their
wealth and the ability to survive
therefore they will become dependent on
the central controllers on big Tech
social media companies and these
billionaires eugenicists and and other
crazy people who do believe that they
will be living forever as you mentioned
from that comment by Jared Kushner who
who openly said hey I'm taking care of
my body I'm going to be living forever
he said that pretty confidently and
that's something that of course people
should be thinking about the larger
ramifications of because if we have
Elites that are living forever what's
that what is everyone else going to be
living to and how are they going to be
controlled and stopped from living from
ever and these people are essentially
creating a situation where they're going
to be the next gods and they're making
themselves Gods through this fourth
Industrial Revolution with the
technological progression that we have
been making that is extremely dangerous
and has a lot of implications that we
haven't even thought about so are you
saying the Democrats are going to lose
it it doesn't matter because the the
billionaire Bankers will bankroll and
finance both of them and then screw
everyone else over let me let me uh I'll
pull up this story right here from Yahoo
news Jared Kushner says he's been trying
to keep his body in shape because he
might One Day become immortal
Kushner former president Donald Trump's
son-in-law said during a live stream
this week he was keeping Trim in the
event that medical science allows him to
live forever during the stream Kushner
said that he had made it a priority to
exercise more after leaving the White
House where he served as a senior
advisor to Trump okay let's just is this
it yep that's it and then finally I
think that
from uh you know the last year the one
thing I've tried to put a priority on
since I left the White House was you
know getting some exercise in I think
that there's a a good probability that
my generation is hopefully with the
advances in science either you know the
the first generation to live forever or
the last generation that's going to die
and so uh we need to keep ourselves in
in pretty good shape and I went to a
meeting in Los Angeles with the
organization I think was called the
senescence Foundation have you heard of
that a scientist this was a decade ago
this is longer than a decade ago this is
12 years ago scientists by the name of
Aubrey de gray was giving a presentation
and I think he was the one who said this
that he said people under the age of 45
today will live to be will live forever
and I I could be it's been a long time
since he may have said lived to be a
thousand or something and he said it's
not because in the next 10 years they're
going to invent immortality or some kind
of treatment it's that the rate of
solving human ailments will outpace the
rate at which people are dying from
ailments so that means when you're 80
and your heart is failing they will have
developed a treatment to strengthen and
Revitalize your heart then you live till
a hundred then your brain starts going
but by then they've already developed
the brain treatment to fix your brain
then the skin treatment then by the time
you're 300 years old they've got a
treatment for everything and now you're
basically 300 but you look like you're
24. telling you man if they have you in
a tank of Goo that you're moving very
slowly your body's not aging rapidly or
maybe not even aging at all
that's the thing they don't need you in
the tank of goo and actually my
girlfriend and you think they want you
to be immortal they're talking about
life extension technology Jason is dying
to talk here I'm going to let him talk
in just a little bit but I just want to
interject with two more points here uh
sorry this is like the old days here I
love it uh but but Kushner again he's
not a good person he's the guy who
personally lobbied Donald Trump to bomb
Syria Donald Trump personally listened
to him to do this he also personally
lobbied to give a better weapons deal to
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia that's
committing one of the worst humanitarian
crises right now in Yemen these are not
good people and these are these are the
next people who are going to be gods in
our society this is crazy Jason go ahead
so you talked about Aubry to gray my
girlfriend actually interviewed him
yesterday and uh yeah we were watching
uh immortality Inc which was a forum
that he was on with Calico by the way
the immortality vision of Google and I
love alphabet it's one alphabet's
company yes and then Richard Harari
who's a part of I think longevity Inc
and you know we study this stuff and
he's talking about like you said
regenerative technology in other words
really de-aging and repairing the human
body so that physiologically you could
live for an indefinite amount of time
now this is why the sustainability
agenda is extremely dangerous okay and
it's like how would they get there so
everybody saw Joe at the global health
fund kind of go off to the side and look
very confused and not not know what he
was doing right anybody actually listen
to what he said
in a room full of people first of all
introduced by Bill Gates up on stage
with Trudeau macron all these other
players he talked about how the return
for this financially for those that will
invest is 31 to 1 in returns now a lot
of people have told me who do I call to
invest in them well I mean if you want
to get in on it basically he said for
the nation states and ngos that are
putting in 1 billion the United States
is going to put in 2 billion okay and
guess who's paying for that 2 billion
it's me and you I mean that's going to
be taxpayer money but while they bring
in these modes of control we're going to
be talking about
insurmountable profits for these people
so they're motivated to control us and
command us into these systems by profit
and we pay for it Biden maybe just you
know an empty vassal he can still kind
of read off the prompter so that is the
agenda in my opinion and while they do
that sustainability is the code word for
our standard of living going down down
they're consolidating the actual
resources and the control over
Technologies such as I don't know if
you've seen this but there's several
articles about it of bunkers in case
things pop off here whether it be that
nuclear war or something else and
they're utilizing NASA Tech what if they
already discovered immortality and then
like all these wealthy Elites like at a
company whatever Calico is at the
company yeah that's when alphabets come
from let's let's say they're sitting
around and they're like
so uh guys
we did it we've figured out immortality
and then how much does it cost actually
not that expensive maybe like 50 Grand a
person and your treatment will make you
live forever and then someone else went
but we don't want most of these people
to live forever they're kind of you know
kind of [ __ ] what do we do
how can we wipe out all of the people
before giving Only the Good People
immortality because if you give Only the
Good People the immortality you're only
biologically Immortal you can still get
crushed by a semi or something right
so what if
I suppose what I'm trying to get at is
if all of this stuff is true and they
really believe that certainly Vladimir
Putin knows a lot about this why then
would he choose to go to war against it
either I think the obvious thing is
because he mentioned Satanism and weird
stuff
he ideologically opposes whatever this
is maybe it's coming from a religious
place or he knows he's in on it and
they're trying to call all of the nasty
poor people they don't like your
original Theory makes a lot of sense
here because a lot of the the central
controllers and Elites that you
mentioned that might have life extension
technology already do already act like
vampires and witches and a lot of them
do look like vampires and witches so a
lot of this makes perfect sense in my
opinion sorry you had something to say
Jason I mean when we speculate on these
things right whether or not there's some
kind of collusion behind the scenes on
these Technologies all I can say is
there is still collusion between Russia
and the United States on a level that
we're working together uh just last week
in Kazakhstan Russia launched a U.S
astronaut into space with two Russian
astronauts they're still joint missions
going on at the ISS I think a lot of
that has to do with post-world War II
and the space race and the fact that
Russia was the first one to put
satellites into space that created arpa
into DARPA we know about the Strategic
Defense Initiative Program AKA Reagan's
Star Wars program we know that Russia
has comparable satellite systems and
weapon systems and space as well there
was also cyber polygon a joint network
with the world economic forum and Russia
and the United States working on war
games and drills of a larger Cyber
attack on infrastructure that of course
is also important to to bring up that
happened a couple months ago yeah so so
behind the scenes I
is a lair that goes a little bit further
now as to how far that layer goes I
think that's where you get into
speculation Kissinger Henry Kissinger
one of my favorite people on earth is 90
99 years old at the moment or I guess
yeah he's 99 he'll be 100 in about six
months I wonder if it's like they've
already established life longevity but
they're like how long until they realize
that we're not dead like what if I'm 130
and they're still like a wonderful ever
of Life of extension uh they're 160 and
they're like when are we gonna develop
well living forever let me say this
cryogenics is still a very real thing
whether or not you're going to be able
to reanimate life after being
cryogenically frozen again kind of a
speculative thing but that technology
does exist is pushed very much in these
transhumanist fronts and I would argue
that a lot of these people at the top
already do really live longer lives than
the vast majority of us you just said
Kissinger is 99 yeah look at Prince
Philip well into his 90s David Rockville
was like 101 when he died and then what
happens is even John Rockefeller like
the queen like once you're a world
leader and you die what they really do
is bring you to the Genesis chamber
where they de-age you and then claim
you're a lost nephew or something yeah
they hit you with a Large Hadron
Collider John D Rockefeller
for the internet's sake I'm joking by
the way I bet they've been doing life
extension for if they had this
technology we would not be knowing about
it let's be real John Rockefeller 98
years old in the 1800s he lives always
98. what about uh Walt Disney isn't
there a conspiracy that Walt Disney uh
froze himself that's the cryogen that
allegedly they made Frozen as a way to
cover that up that's what that's a rumor
that I heard yesterday yeah the main
reason that they made uh the movie
Frozen was to of course make people look
up Frozen Disney and they wouldn't find
out how you know the former head of
Disney Frozen that is the best
conspiracy theory ever you mentioned
speculation Jason I want to speculate
you think do you think that there's
behind the scenes a larger I don't know
if cabal is the right word but class of
people or people that are attempting to
create a class system of wealthy you
know yeah Immortals they're the Predator
class well those are the just the open
transhumanists I don't think you have to
speculate on that you can actually go
into someone like Ray kurzwell who is
the head of Calico and he's been writing
about these things for live literally 30
years okay now he argues that basically
biological life on the planet is going
to end and we are going to replace it
with something that is not carbon based
and these entities that we create will
be so convincing that they have
sentience and spiritual
um uh how do you say it spiritual
experiences that we will kind of cut our
own throats and allot them laws in which
they're able to take power and they're
going to be so convincing because
they're going to be smarter than us now
I know this sounds incredibly wild but
Kurzweil you know he's the guy behind
the Kurzweil keyboard he's the guy that
predicted the iPad and the iPhone
30 plus years beforehand and I don't say
that just because you got those
predictions right that he'll get these
ones right but he's one of these people
that talks about not only the virtual
world but also talks about energy and
here's the thing so we're all worried
about carbon credits and we're worried
about our carbon footprint that's the
big buzz term you gotta be worried about
your carbon footprint and how much uh
bad things you're doing to uh
the environment well Kurzweil argues
that by 2030 we're going to be able to
harness so much solar power which is
still a fraction that we would be able
to power the entire world and all of its
knees 10 times over so you know
overpopulation is a myth so there are
some points that I actually agree with
kurz well and I look into his warnings
and there are other things like I don't
think that we can become sentient beings
of light in this Singularity that he
talks about approaching now at the same
time you do have these open
bioengineering programs and for instance
two weeks ago I think it is now you had
this new executive order on the bio
economy and sustainability where they
talk about monetizing
um the biology of the citizenry of this
country and how they're going to do that
and they're looking into that forget
about cbdc's that's interesting enough
but this whole Economy based on your
biology really works into what Klaus in
the gang Klaus nut likes to talk about
with this fourth Industrial Revolution
that it becomes you when you're
monetizing the biology is that like uh
if your body has a certain genetic
algorithm or code that that will produce
more credits for you'll be you'll be a
richer person because your genetics are
different clausch literally talked about
having microchips inside of people
fantasizing about this on stage at one
of his meetings saying it would be great
to be able to feel everyone and everyone
would be able to feel me through a
digital online computer that's that's in
their in their brain so you can yeah
this is like the Borg it sounds like
from Starbucks literally well to answer
your question what they'll do is they'll
look at your physiology and then they'll
have an algorithm based on how much work
you can get done whatever the task they
give you to do that right and then
you'll probably be paid in a digit
digitized tokenized system in the social
credit score based on how you performed
right it's just like neural Pathways
firing accuracy and things like that if
you look into for instance Rand
Corporation put out a document called
human brain interfaces 2040 and they go
beyond even the neuralink type devices
where and then this is also very
curswellian where you would just inject
bio nanotech and that would basically
overtake your nervous system and not
only that but the bio nano technology
once it gets into the trillions in your
brains it can actually shut off your
version of reality in other words what
when I'm touching this and holding this
and instead allow you to feel different
physical and mental problems bro that's
that's the neural link thing right well
without neural link well no but but what
I mean is the idea is when they invent
neurolink you're going to have these
things these implants or I should say
they're working on it now but once they
get to read write access in your mind
the idea is like you'll wake up in the
morning and you'll go on you'll eat
breakfast and then you'll go gotta go to
work you'll turn the neural link on and
your eyes will like roll into the back
of your head and you're just like and
then your body will zombie walk to
McDonald's where you're flipping burgers
but in your mind you're fighting dragons
all day dude you'll be like this these
eggs need more salt ah much saltier now
like you'll just taste something
different because you use your app the
mom's gonna be like kids honey what do
you guys want to have for dinner do you
want to have you know a Wolfgang Puck or
do you want to have uh Gordon Ramsay oh
let's do Gordon Ramsay and then she
brings out a bunch of tofu cubes and
cricket cricket mush and she puts on the
table and she goes okay and swipe swipe
and Gordon Ramsay we were joking about
this right now but a thousand schools in
Australia are feeding children Cricket
products and they're eating bugs already
in Australia Australia is one of the
governments that have has been pushing a
lot of these policies forward more than
any other government out there
especially when it came to their coveted
policies especially now when it comes to
their climate policies and before all of
this their policies restricting people's
ability to be able to defend themselves
and also have firearms so they are on
the precipice they had they have the
most amount of of young leaders coming
from the world economic Forum
influencing their government and their
government is literally talking about
implementing a central bank digital
currency they have they have they have
already set up literally quarantine
camps inside of their country that they
spent 580 million dollars building that
only housed sorry imprisoned
2168 people according to Rebel news
that's account for nearly a quarter
million dollars per guest during the
covid uh did you say a thousand kids a
thousand schools a thousand schools
spectator Australia a thousand
Australian schools are fed insects you
will eat the bugs you will live in the
Pod you will owe nothing and you will be
happy yeah we laugh about this we make
jokes about this but this is a reality
in a lot of places around the world
where this agenda is already moving
forward word in many deceivious ways
under the guise of of helping people
that's not helping people there's a
there's a lot of controversy especially
when it comes to the nutritional value
especially when it comes to the larger
physical effects that people have when
they do eat bugs a lot of people don't
like to talk about this but the science
a lot of it is bunk a lot of it is of
course financed by individuals like Bill
Gates that have an invested interest in
pushing this and and why do they watch
any bugs so bad well they're making
because they understand that that if a
person is healthy they're not as
dependent as of course the person who is
unhealthy and I think there's a big
agenda to make people unhealthy and I
think this is why there's such a war
against meat what a lot of these people
who call for this this kind of
Singularity who call for this fourth
Industrial Revolution a lot of what they
have in common is also their bigger
fight against meat meat one of the most
you know nutritiously densed food out
there you take away meat from the
general public as Bill Gates says he
wants Western Society to be completely
meatless in the next few years when when
you take away
people's nutrition you take away their
ability for for them to be strong and to
resist the larger takeover of humanity
which is happening right now Bill Gates
is not uh the image of health absolutely
not oh yeah he has members are you
talking about man haven't you seen that
new corn video have you seen the new
Corner oh yeah you haven't seen the porn
video of course I've seen it okay he's
looking pretty fit
he's I think I think he's he's obese I
don't know if he's morbidly obese but
he's obese big yeah he's a he's a big
fella you know that Bill Gates he's sad
you got one job Bill be be the uh the
version of what you want to see in
people no this is what it's going to be
you're going to be eating bugs while
morbidly obese Bill Gates has got a
mutton Chopper or was it a what is it
mutton is it the big leg or whatever and
he's gonna be like
eat your crickets is there any way to
Ally with the Borg and come out better
for it no no it assimilates you're just
looking out for yourself this is like
screw you guys like plug me into the
Matrix let me taste that juicy steak in
the metaverse is that what you're like I
feel like it's inevitably happening like
where it's the Avalanches cascading
we're riding it down the cliff right now
towards the everyone people plugging in
whether you want to or not that Society
will and then we'll either you'll become
dangerous to society if you're not in it
or you'll be forced to because you can't
compete in the job market and you start
to starve unless you get it but like if
you're in there like I think Captain
Captain Jean-Luc Picard got assimilated
by the borgans somehow from within the
network was able to twist it but I could
be wrong about that no no he was he was
in and they had to break him out like
there's no the Borg assimilates
everything in its path I don't think
there's obviously you could you could
create like some sort of Trojan from
inside the system but
I mean that's what I want to look at
this picture let's just be wrong I could
be wrong that it's that it's an
avalanche in process but what do you get
that Vibe like this this is what you're
fighting for I think that they're moving
in that direction and that no matter
what happens politically there will be
certain organizations that continue this
work right I don't think you're going to
be able to get rid of all of it okay but
at the same time I think that they
vastly overestimate how much they're
going to be able to control the general
populace meanwhile empowering themselves
with the real technology right once
technology goes public and people have
their hands on it that's when the real
Innovations always begin right and
that's where you have the true Maverick
so I'm hoping that as this stuff rolls
out it's the underground that utilizes
it to empower Humanity instead of
enslave us just like a hammer can build
a house it can bash someone's head in
and they're trying to bash their heads
in well look at look at this remember
everybody this is what you're fighting
for that's right that's mutton
is that Rosemary on top
and just tearing up meat while you're on
the ground in a potato sat wearing a
potato sack and you're gonna have a bowl
of crickets and you're gonna be like
thank you master
and he's gonna back get out of my side
so that's the world they want so if you
haven't seen upload okay oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah have you seen it Hulu or
something it's on Amazon yeah Amazon but
it is this idea that you don't have to
worry about dying anymore that you are
going to upload your Consciousness and
you know not to give away too much of
the plot but that's what they want for
the plebeian class and the plebian class
is eating the printed foods and the
plebian class is living in small
apartments like your dorm so in other
words you're on these dating apps but
they're not dating apps they're pure
hookup apps everything's everything's
recorded so your Sexes recorded
everything and you're having sex next to
your roommate right and they just have
like a VR helmet so they're not paying
attention you're in like a four by four
room you're going on dates where your
food's printed and then you get to the
people that are running the show
and they have chicken and they have
steak and they're not driving the
automated vehicles that are this big and
they're not in the small apartments
humans when the rich people die they get
uploaded to like the Estates where it's
like this luxurious afterlife and poor
people have pay as you go where they're
in like the sterile white box and if you
talk too much you're burning through
data and then you just get Frozen when
you run out and someone's got to re-up
you so you just Zonk out and then you
come to a month later when someone
finally pays the bill to turn you back
on
or you got to fill out the Excel sheets
and do all the lame paperwork for all
the ruling leads you know it even has a
voting aspect to it so you know one of
the running themes is somebody who's you
know already uploaded themselves and
then can leave that Universe through one
of these entities or robots that they
build yeah that you've seen it
um and they talk about how the reason
they're doing this and they're offering
a free upload like you said most of
these are monetized and there are
certain tiers but there's this place you
can go to now that's kind of like this
utopian upload and like people are
getting in line and bringing their
babies with them because it's their only
chance and once you upload you're dead
see that's the kind of running joke it
it takes your entire head off right but
one of the reasons that there they
bought this infrastructure and bringing
people into it is because they want to
change the voting uh Records so
basically they want certain candidates
in and they want to get rid of the class
of people that would vote against those
candidates dystopic twist the people
that are eating the chicken and the lamb
while the plebs are all in their cars
are also going to be eating human meat
because what you said they're cut them
off at the neck they keep the brain
alive so that the person doesn't know
that they're just a brain but they take
the bodies for consumption
people are gonna have to eat people
they're not gonna people are going to
have nobody's gonna have to do it
they're saying they want once they get
the taste it's gonna be like oh this is
perfect and it's a population reduction
oh man that's a little too much for me
let's put it yeah but that's why we've
got to make a movie about it first you
may just want to bring a little cannibal
story it's so bizarre don't even know if
I we we're going off the deep end we got
to save something for the members I mean
do you guys know about this Utah case at
all what Utah case so there's a case out
in Utah right now that is into
ritualistic child abuse okay and
apparently there was an investigation
that happened in the 80s and the 90s
that was thrown out of court
it was revamped this year during an
election year to the point where a
person named David Levitt went on public
television and said
I don't abuse children and I'm not a
cannibal these are all lies and you're
like taken back whoa what's going on
here
and basically if you reread this case he
was named with a group of other people
into some really like Texas Chainsaw
Massacre type stuff on children the
stuff that you couldn't believe
well one of his associates got arrested
this week named David Hamblin and David
Hamblin got arrested for hypnotizing and
sexually abusing children while taping
them at the six and seven year old range
and this is in that same time period And
they also arrested another person in law
enforcement in Utah that may or may not
be connected now these people are being
held without bond or bail either and
Levitt lost his election he was I think
a Utah County prosecutor and many people
believe that he's going to be the next
to be arrested once his term is actually
up and they're waiting for that because
he already knew these guys and he knew
he was the one being investigated now
when these kind of stories come out I'm
just like taken aback because I don't
know one way or another but the children
seem to obviously be abused they have
the physical evidence that they were and
they have a bunch of eyewitness uh
testimony so it's interesting I want to
jump to this story and talk about the
future of humanity and man the guardian
study links in uterus forever chemical
exposure to low sperm count and Mobility
pfas now found in nearly all umbilical
cord blood around the world interfere
with hormones crucial to testicle
development could this be why there are
so many soy boys they say
polyfluoro alkyl polyfluoro alcohol
substances are known to disrupt hormones
and Fetal development and future
reproductive capacity is largely defined
as defined as testicles developed in
utero during the first trimester of a
pregnancy said study co-author Sandra
sogard totenberg probably pronouncing
that wrong of the Copenhagen University
Hospital quote it makes sense that
exposure to substances that mimic and
interfere with hormones involved in this
delicate process can have consequences
for semen quality later in life yeah but
if you're talking about you know
mangling up somebody's uh somebody's
boys while they're in the womb isn't
that going to impact a lot more than
that
you know we got a lot of soy boys with
low sperm counts could it be that these
pfas chemicals I was talking about this
because a lot of people
you know uh seemed seem to have
forgotten when Alex Jones came out and
said they were turning the frogs gay
it's talking about atrazine and
endocrine disruptors so I was saying
it's also pcbs and phthalates there's a
bunch of studies showing that those
things can mess with people's brains and
development now we've got this story
this is from this is from today on the
guardian this new study saying that
these these chemicals polyfluoroalkyl is
that you pronounce I don't know I think
so uh is lowering sperm counts and I got
to imagine what you know the ubiquitous
chemicals are estimated to be 98 of
Americans blood and they can cross the
placental barrier and accumulate in the
growing fetus a recent analysis of 40
studies of umbilical cord blood from
around the world found that pfas were
detected in all 30 000 samples
so someone want to look this up what are
these what is this chemical for and why
is it everywhere why is everybody got it
yeah why not why well they're called
Forever chemicals because they're
impossible to get rid of and they keep
being persistent and there's no natural
way of them being filtered out or dealt
with this is why some people call them
forever chemicals and this is why some
scientists have labeled them this I try
to look up the nihs.gov page on it and
it says it no longer exists are you
getting that era well I got it I got it
here on Wikipedia per and polyfloral
alkyl substances
and uh it just explains what it is but
I'm wondering like why is it everywhere
you know like a lot of this a lot of a
lot of people can make us to to plastic
whoa look at this look at this and
non-stick chemicals yeah Teflon and or
aqueous film forming foam
so what what are we scraping the Teflon
off the pl the pans and yeah non-stick
pans and a lot of our packaging and a
lot of our consumer goods a lot of our
clothing also is is filled with a lot of
chemicals that absolutely affect us
there's pfas there's microplastics
there's other endocrine disruptors
there's seed oils there's people not
getting any kind of sunlight there's
vitamin deficient diets there's so many
things you could point to when it comes
to the destruction the the physical
destruction of the Modern Man and when I
when I tweeted this story I tweeted
there's a secret chemical War for your
balls your ball your balls are losing
and when you look at the rates of of
testosterone you look at the rates of
sperm counts dramatically declining in
dangerous levels to the point where
Jared kushner's comments could be
correct when he said we might live
forever or we might be the last people
to die because because people aren't
having children people can't have
children miscarriages are up
dramatically as well and this to me is a
part of the larger deep regulation
agenda that is also plaguing the world
right now I I think you know the mistake
that Jared Kushner made when he said
that he was you know going to live
forever be the last to die is that if
there's one thing you want to avoid when
you're hated by Millennial leftists is
Harry Potter references and you know
Voldemort was like only I can live
forever and so for Jared cushion to go
on TV and say something like that it's
like dude they're already calling Trump
Voldemort you don't need to help them
out with the only cultural reference
they have right
I've been thinking about these pfas like
we're talking about uh perfluorocal and
like I microwave plastic I probably
should stop doing it completely but yeah
like these bacon these single wrap
bacons and I put it in the microwave for
10 seconds and then eat it and it's like
just the the plastic is like rubberized
when I pull it just eat the plastic it's
just just take it all people are finding
plastic in people's lungs in people's
blood that's how far Plastics have uh
impacted Humanity that's that's a level
that is not normal that is not okay that
is affecting our human bodies in very
negative ways you know out of all the
chemicals I didn't hear anybody mention
bisphenol a and BPA was the first thing
to wake me up via Alex Jones when I was
working him with him in 2009 I think and
I remember my girlfriend at the time we
were sitting there talking and I brought
it up and I said you know this stuff is
in our plastics it's leaching it's in a
lot of our canned goods and she goes
Jason I just I can't they they no Jason
they're not feminizing people they would
never do that and you wonder yourself is
this part of a larger program to utilize
these chemicals in everyday products to
really change Humanity no I think it's
more likely that a company you know when
Plastics were first developed you got to
understand go to these antique shops
everything's metal and glass it's really
crazy to see a can of juice you know
it's like a big count on oil can it's
like wow now everything is plastic these
days it's a lot cheaper it's a lot
easier to mold and then all of a sudden
they started saying like hey maybe this
is really really bad and you get these
bottled water companies and they're
sending they're going so what are you
telling me well the phthalates and the
plastic are leaching into the water
because it's sitting for too long and
you got biophenols and polyphenols
people are ingesting it and it's causing
problems in their endocrine system and
their kids okay so what do we do you got
to get rid of the plastic you know
that's going to cost us billions of
dollars we can't afford that the company
which cease to exist how much to make
the study go away that what I think is
more likely is that there's too much
developed in the economy into using
Plastics nobody nobody's going to want
to go back to using metal everything
it's too heavy plastic super that's why
you need graphene because it's
lightweight carbon The Only Way Forward
is to get away from Plastics is to go
into graphene I think it'd be fine it's
the best way if all like we discovered
in like 70 years graphene leeches into
your water and then people are drinking
it well at least it's graphene is the
next lead well it's carbon it's not it's
not lead it's not pla it's I mean
Plastics are carbon based too but it's
just pure carbon so hopefully it's not
as bad
yeah and everything's got a downside to
it I think that Plastics are crazy I've
heard and I don't know if you guys can
confirm this that all the fluoride that
has been maybe not all but fluoride
being put in the water was partly
Industrial Waste they didn't know what
to do with the industrial fluoride waste
so they were just like just put it in
the water it's the aluminum waste
conspiracy theory aluminum wage it's the
aluminum waste because there's different
types of fluoride so you have uh stands
at fluoride and then you actually have
uh calcium fluoride which is natural and
has very different properties so you can
drink water that has calcium fluoride in
it and it's not going to give you the
same effects as the aluminum byproduct
that you're talking about which is
um stands of fluoride so maybe those
were conflated in what I'd read I don't
know maybe they're putting the calcium
fluoride in the water well no I believe
that the calcium is only there naturally
in that whether I remember okay so we'll
go back to Infowars I remember when Rob
dou went to the Austin water plan and
the bags of the fluorides have the
death's head on them and anybody can go
watch those videos but it says look this
isn't a concentrated form this is
extremely deadly I'm not sure that we
would want to put that in uh water even
in diluted form would we but somehow
we're doing that it's the most
electrically uh what's elastic chemical
uh element fluorine and that means it's
the most likely to take an electron away
from something else causing free radical
damage well also it's important to note
here that a lot of the hormones a lot of
the prescription drugs that a lot of
people are on uh especially when it
comes to things like birth control those
never really get filtered out there's no
way of kind of getting rid of those
chemicals and a lot of times public
drinking water is found to have
substances that are from Big Pharma that
were never filtered out that do have an
effect on human beings and I think that
also plays into the bigger role of
what's Happening Here when it comes to
the the chemical castration of the
modern man that is being chemically uh
and you know engineered
to uh be the way that the men are and I
think it's only going to get worse from
here I want to clarify uh fluorine is
the most electronegative element I think
electronegativity is a type of Electro
elasticity meaning that it's but
electronegativity means it's will it's
most likely to snag an electron away
from something and cause molecular
breakdown take a look at this graphic
the effects of of pfas
it includes low birth weight obesity
early puberty onset this is in babies
pregnancy-induced hypertension
preeclampsia increased time to pregnancy
low sperm count and Mobility increased
miscarriage risk and it negatively
impacts everybody else as well that
Wikipedia's got a study up here it's
actually an older study from from last
year February 2021 hormone disrupting
chemicals including pfas are linked with
rapid declines in human fertility
there you go baby and they call them
forever chemicals these pfas because
they and technically not forever but is
it larger in plastic
I don't know I stopped eating it I heard
horrible things about it yeah it is
horrible
margarine ingredients I mean
Mar is it true that margarine is almost
plastic
almost yeah uh it is not it's a
misinterpretation is that it is
chemically speaking yes margarine is
almost plastic because it has all the
same molecules as plastic except for one
but it isn't how organic compounds work
like literally anything margarine is for
my molecule since everything is blah
blah blah blah blah okay yeah I don't
know man I can tell the difference
between butter and margin butter and
margarine I think anybody can I think
everybody can one tastes bad and one
tastes good that's it maybe the quality
of our store-bought butter is just so
awful that you know a lot of people
couldn't tell the difference anymore but
my thing is just stop eating the fake
stuff brominated what is that you know
brominated flowers or something yeah you
got potassium bromate yeah what does
that do it's like a evening agent but
also they found it in yoga mats it's a
chemical that causes what is it like the
fluffiness in yoga mats and then they
put in a bread it's banned in France
it's banned in a lot of Europe
I hear that's like it's like New York
Pizza has a ton of that stuff oh God and
I swear that when you make your own
bread I mean you just you digest it so
easy but a lot of that you don't know
who's got it I mean I can't look at like
Papa John's and that maybe maybe you can
find the ingredients but like you get a
pizza box it doesn't say on the pizza
box if these potassium bromate and the
bread which it probably should we get
you know we got chickens and uh the eggs
are all just weird sizes you go to the
store you open up the egg thing and
they're all identical all white yeah you
go in the in the coop all these
different chickens some are like oblong
some like we we've had one I think
whereas an egg and an egg like that
happens sometimes we have a whole bunch
of double yolks it's just like they're
all different ones like copper brown
one's green one's blue and they're all
shaped different in different sizes and
then I'm reading the ingredients for
like baking it's like two large eggs and
I'm like what does that mean if you go
to the store and you're living in the
modern world you're getting this
mass-produced generic crap you open it
all the eggs are the same for me I'm
like I don't know what two eggs means
these ones are big these ones are small
what am I supposed to give me many
ounces of egg or something but I'm just
bringing this up because for one you all
know that I love chickens but what I'm
trying to say is you should be doing
what you can to eat as naturally as
possible we don't we don't have these we
do have plastic water bottles
but I make a point to buy glass water
bottles and we have Reef we typically
have reusable uh glass water bottles
that we fill up with our own filters
added minerals so we're on well water so
we don't got any gunk in it there's
natural Gunk that exists in well water
obviously but you filter it out it's got
this UV thing that the water passed
through killing all the bacteria and
then we put it in glass bottles and we
bring it up to the studio or we just get
these these aquapanna Toscana Italy
Italian water we're drinking Italian
water and glass bottles look at us huh
you know I got a fancy pants here but
but there's a big difference between
store-bought eggs and and eggs that you
naturally have from your own chickens
but you also should test your land for
lead if you are going to be eating those
eggs and to clarify potassium bromate is
not the stuff in yoga mats it's called
azodicarbonamide it's a dough
conditioner that also they put that in
our pizza they put uh it's an industrial
blowing agent azodicarbonamide known to
trigger asthma but then it's breakdown
it's it's the breakdown products of azo
dicarbamide
um
yeah it's in it's in doe azodicarbon of
mine is a dough conditioner it also is
an industrial blowing agent
you know what's nasty as hydrogenated
oils
it's just you got to get back to butter
and cream man oh I don't like butter and
cream butter and cream yeah but so you
know Luke's been talking about seed oils
and all that stuff too you got the trans
fats you got hydrogenated oils and all
those other weird garbage there was this
place I remember it was an ice cream
shop I'm Gonna Keep the details vague
because I don't want to rag on them but
I go to this place and they say it was a
vegan it was it was vegan ice cream or
whatever and I was like oh what does
that mean and they said there's no dairy
in any of our ice cream you just get ice
cubes it was it was basically they took
Crisco hydrogenated vegetable shortening
with sugar and flavor and then churned
it and then it tastes good and so when I
when I was like what is it it's
basically like vegetable oil whipped and
Frozen I'm like that's gross yeah it I'm
gonna eat the cream from the cow and I'm
gonna enjoy it in New Hampshire they had
the exact opposite of that there's a
there's a farm where I usually stay at
that that has a bunch of cows that are
just running around not not in big
factories but are free to roam and they
have an ice cream place and they make
the ice cream from the raw milk from the
cows that are in the pasture and it is
like the most incredible ice cream you
could ever have there's pup cups that my
dog goes absolutely crazy for I I just
got her like a store pup cup she doesn't
care she doesn't want it but but that
one with the raw milk she just went all
milk is illegal well depends depends on
what you're doing with it if you're
trading it within state lines there's a
bunch of jurisdiction and bureaucracy
and government what they do out here and
but they passed the law in New Hampshire
where you could make ice cream out of it
and and and yeah what they do is you buy
a percentage of a co-op and now as an
owner you can have the raw milk and then
it's like you just gotta pay your share
or whatever so you as an owner you're
allowed to have it there's also what
they do is they sell it as pet milk
saying not for human consumption but
everybody else what that means so
they'll they'll tell you it's like oh
it's for pets and they'll grab it and
they'll just drink it it's like uh sure
whatever I mean for that matter you
could eat dog food it probably doesn't
taste good I wouldn't recommend it but
it's not like I don't know probably
shouldn't but if you've got the Nanobots
in your brain and it tastes like ground
beef so so be it right it's going to
have all the nice little nutrients in it
your little dog food your pellets so but
so here's a question though
if is it a bad thing if you could
open up an app and make your bad food
taste like good food I mean is that bad
food actually good for you
physiologically well let's just say the
let's just say you've got have you ever
had Soylent
so I remember when Soylent first came
out and it was like I guess the name was
supposed to be a gag and the idea was to
make total meal replacement it's
impossible to do by the way because
humans are unique so what they realized
was when they put all of the stuff and
then oil into this one shake
if you're six foot five it's not going
to do it for you if you're five foot
five it might be too much but anyway
this stuff when it first came out tasted
like cardboard I'm not trying to be mean
it literally tasted like cardboard but
it had all these delicious nutrients
would it be a bad thing if you could
just be like press a button it tastes
like a chocolate milkshake
that's tough you're getting good
nutrients everything you need all right
there and it's not made of people it's
just it was it was like made of oats and
vitamins I mean that's the question do
you want to live in an illusion or
reality is that really an illusion I
mean you're getting your nutrients and
the reality is it tastes great even
though it doesn't taste great unless you
are I guess biochemically changed you
wouldn't want to flick the switch on the
neural link and then be transported into
Middle Earth where you're battling you
know a big fan of reality Tim reality
I'm a big fan of reality I I listen I
like the VR stuff too I'm a video gamer
as well hell I'm replaying uh Saints Row
2 right now you know for a little R and
R but I think when you get to the point
where you can no longer tell the
difference between what is reality and
what is a virtual environment you have
many many ethical questions that
obviously run down to the extremes of
what the Matrix presents and if you're
going to do that with food in particular
you know how do you know know that it's
actually as healthy for you unless
you're getting your blood work done
every week or every month or we do have
the internet of bodies where literally
that program is running it you don't
know we've been lied to how many times
about what's in our food what's in our
medicines what's in the you know the
products that we use to keep up with our
hygiene such as just aluminum and
deodorants and that's on a micro level
so for me I'll take the real deal
anytime I'll take the delicious cream
Amish ice cream that I used to have in
Fort Plain and it was delicious like you
said you'd actually see them pour the
milk into the machine it would come out
and be like sweet and be like oh my
goodness I can't get this in a store
I think you can replicate a lot of
things but at the end of the day it's
really just a cheap imitation
yeah almost everything in the
supermarket is trying to kill you that's
what I say and scream out loud as I'm
walking through the supermarket and be
like hey this is cancer this is going to
kill you and everyone's looking at me
like I'm crazy because I kind of am
but uh partly true I get these this Tech
is like bending your state of mind for
you so you don't have to do it yourself
like when you eat a food you can kind of
decide am I gonna let make myself enjoy
this or am I going to let myself find it
gross psilocybin mushrooms for instance
for me I know they grow on cow poop so
when I taste it it tastes like salty cow
poop I'm like oh I'm gonna vomit and I
think about it it makes me nauseous but
then I'm like no no it just tastes like
salty chewy goodness and I'm tasting it
it's like actually it's really good so
like the neural net can do that for me
but I have to override my own sensual
perceptions to force myself to see it in
a new way I think it's lazy to rely on
technology to do that for us I already
know what's gonna happen
it's going to be like 15 years from now
Ian's going to have like his hairs cut
really short he's wearing a suit me and
Luke are going to be like running
through a sewer with like you know
plasma rifles and then we're gonna we're
like running through it's like dark and
there's a little light shining down and
looks like go left left we turn left and
all sudden like a robot comes out and
then fires like it's fists and like
knocks us back Ian walks up from behind
us and goes stop running just accept it
and we're like Ian what happened to you
man and then he grabs us and he sticks
the neural Linker we're like no
my voice
oh geez did you ever read a wrinkle in
time I love that book it's my favorite
the youngest 20 something the youngest
brother goes and interfaces with the
brain and then becomes part of the brain
and it's like man he's just is the brain
now it's completely taken over him and
don't they also have those kind of fake
environments when they go like when the
main character goes into the City and
everybody's kind of an automatically
yeah yes yeah these are gray and white
and black and then but they don't see it
that way the people in the brain and the
Machine don't they see gorgeous do you
guys read the sequel to it no no there's
a sequel to it it was one of those books
they made us read when we were kids yeah
and I barely remember any of it but I
did read that and then I think the
sequel was called a wind in the door or
something like that yeah wind at the
door they made us they made a movie and
then nobody wanted to see it yeah I I
showed it to my nieces but I couldn't
get into it it had Oprah in it it could
be that interfacing with the machine is
like the one ring like I think I can
handle it I think I can go in and then
somehow help people break out when the
time is when the moment is right but
that I'll get get lost in it and then
people like you'll save I wake up that's
why Ian's gonna be chasing down me and
Luke as we're running through the sewers
like on the Darth Vader character that
thought I could handle it and you guys
are like no it's too much no you're just
like once you have the neural link
you'll understand and then he grabs Luke
and I'm like oh no it looks like help
and then he sticks at Luke's neck and
then looks like everything is great Tim
you'll enjoy it too and I'm like no look
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com click that little
join us button because we're gonna have
a members only uncensored show coming up
at 11 PM over at timcast.com but now we
will read your super jets and we have
many Michael painter says YouTube Just
terminated Mercado law he was live
streaming the Wisconsin Christmas parade
Massacre Court proceedings we've heard
it is I call Shenanigans
usls says you you guys are not ready for
Jason Burma's Burmese Brigade we are
here
technically it's the Boomer Brigade you
love that Boomer stuff what are you like
three years apart Luke could pick up
like three years old it doesn't matter
you still are dude if anyone gets a
chance to have a conversation with Jason
burmiss I highly recommend it it was
mental boot camp like I said earlier on
the show I've already learned a ton of
stuff we'll just use all those tabs for
them for the members only yeah all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says out of the
ashes Rises a rooster of monumental hen
mating Roberto Jr will lead the cast
Castle into the Golden Age of Smashing
the like button gold chains and Luke
milkers though still the second best
Junior
in the you gotta watch the cast Castle
episode that we just put up I don't want
to spoil it so we'll save the spoilers
for the for for next week
but it's Castle Civil War
it's funny
all right
Elisha Kramer says thanks for finally
having Jason on most Discerning mind in
alt media hope you have them on a
regular basis he'd be a great addition
well certainly we'll have Mr Jason back
Let's see we got here khaki fantastic
says love your show I'm a member getting
audio clipping from your mics these past
couple weeks checked across multiple
headsets and devices
I don't know thank you for the feedback
huh get it just kidding but thank You
Restless medic says of course OPEC
screwed the U.S over half of the count
uh half of the countries are either in
the Middle East or North Africa both
have some pretty good reasons to hate
the U.S and our sphere it doesn't
surprise me in the least fourth turning
baby
could it be world war three
I don't know that's one way to phrase it
I don't even know if the definition
matters what we call it right now but
there's definitely a world order shift
or and a lot of people are trying to
decide what it's going to become I would
argue even we're past World War III I
mean what is the war on terror you know
if millions of people die in the Middle
East that's not a World War why you know
what I mean I I guess it's all semantics
but I suppose if you got to the level of
World War III and they were fighting
with tactical nuclear weapons and Beyond
I guess it changes the game OMG puppy
says The World Is Not Afraid Russia will
start a nuclear war they were afraid
that America will start a nuclear war
everyone can see that Biden's
Administration is out of control that's
right it's like that dude was saying on
Bloomberg you know the people in America
can be like Russia must have done this
blowing up Nordstrom everyone else in
the world is like yeah the US did it or
British intelligence
hostile Bogey and bound says with a
geiger counter in my hand I'm going out
to stake me some government land uranium
fever
is that a reference to something huh
that was an awesome awesome chat
John Casey says this is for Jason's
Therapy Group for people who've known
lucrutkowski
again you made a wrong comment Friday
London isn't dividing isn't the dividing
line between East and West Jerusalem is
God's promises are eternal is that what
it is
um oh that that yeah that makes sense
crushes in the west because like Germany
would be considered the West even though
it's east of London right it wouldn't be
considered the East you know what I mean
and much of you yeah yeah let me I'm
gonna double check that right now thank
you for bringing that up
David Scott says no notification for IRL
tonight had to search my subscriptions
be the notification you want to see from
YouTube
because we're hearing more and more
stuff like this a month out from the
election so share the URL to this video
wherever you can actually I forgot to do
that earlier too myself so that's on me
Ian Kitty says if you're going to talk
about the Cuban Missile Crisis don't
forget to talk about operation
Northwoods there is no such thing as
operation Northwoods it's fake news in a
conspiracy and and I have no idea what
you're talking about no I'm just kidding
that was when uh was it LL lemnitzer
proposed blowing up uh planes and
blaming Cuba and then having people
attack Florida and claim it was Cuba and
then JFK was like yo we're not we're not
doing that I think the most interesting
part about that is that the aircraft
that they were going to use in both
cases were remote controlled back in the
60s so they said that they were going to
paint up one of their military aircraft
as a Russian Mig again we're gonna blame
the rooskis and then the commercial
aircraft would also be drone technology
so you had like this double drone false
flag in the works and they even said
they were going to have funerals for
some of the people that were allegedly
on the plane I'm very glad that uh JFK
said no to that plan
um what I was talking about is What's
called the prime meridian it's the
dividing it's where everything west of
it is considered Western longitudinal
everything used is Eastern longitudinal
to the on the and that is through London
England yeah the line of demarcation
Prime Meridian is it it's where it's in
London England it's in uh Greenwich they
call it Greenwich Standard time I think
and that's the zero point so we're like
negative Greenwich to negative five on
the East Coast grafty says declassify
cast Castle number six issues with
playback on the members side 20s uh okay
well if anybody is listening I'll send a
message I don't know do you want to
message somebody yeah what was the
message I guess you're saying that Cass
Castle isn't playing properly or
something I don't know look at that we
will take a look
let's grab some of these super chats
Andre tukalesku says this sounds like
the plot of the sum of all fears
what was that movie about
nuclear war
something like that I didn't see it nope
all right lot Rod mule says hey Tim just
letting all of YouTube know YouTube Just
nuked Rakata law Channel that's right
and we call Shenanigans on that so we'll
we'll I don't know if anyone's heard
anything else but
crispy Joe says FML notifications again
is there a way I can send you proof of
censorship
what did we what was the email we
created ah Shadow ban yeah something
like that I don't remember is it Shadow
band at timcast.com I don't remember
anymore you set it up yeah I know
void Raptor says why is Luke still
wearing those fake tatas are we trying
to stay here huh
that's all muscle that's all muscle baby
Abyss mom says yay Ian is back it has
been tested and it's born without you
mate you keep Tim focused Lids make
y'all the YouTube trinity
that's Abyss mom
poison fist says were lockdowns
practiced for an asteroid Fallout was
the NASA test strike practice radiation
Fallout Global percussive explosions
John E Hoover I don't know what that is
what is that they I know NASA tried to
send an asteroid off course they didn't
try they did it they just did Dart I
mean dart's been a program they've been
uh talking about and here's the thing uh
I think that this is another contrived
way of putting us into fear uh they have
this system that alerts them to how many
asteroids are in the vicinity and that
technology has gotten progressively
better year after year so guess what
they're detecting more and more uh
asteroids in that field year after year
and just last week they actually showed
a video of it uh basically they used
their rocket technology and dart to
Hidden asteroid and blow it off course
and send it in the other direction
Triton 54 says Tim 21-year Navy vet
expertise in nuclear power AC DC
machinery and submarine storage
batteries do you have a need of a master
electrician in Freedom stand willing to
relocate me my German Shepherd my Armory
and FFL immediately
I don't know Luke we got a need for an
FFL I think we could always use an FFL
you know it would be nice to have one
yeah send me an email uh my emails on
timcast.com take a look send me an email
and uh yeah it would be great to have an
armor in a FFL that's something we could
use right absolutely
Raymond g Stanley Jr says a legal
invasion is only if the U.S does it
that's right even without Congressional
approval
how about that huh
yeah
I Kafka says why wouldn't you use nukes
they nuke we respond with normal
conventional Warfare just means they
again use more nukes or am I missing
something if Russia nukes Poland we
respond NATO with conventional Russia
nukes DC we nuke back what I'm saying is
unless they nuke us I don't see the U.S
utilizing nuclear weapons against Russia
maybe giving some to other NATO
countries as a deterrent
I guess we'll only just wait and see uh
I hope you guys have taken this
seriously I'll tell you all the people
in the city who mock Preppers they're
the ones who are concerned right now and
all the peppers are sitting back on a
rocking chair with their cigar just
being like yep this is what I am ready
for
the Anvil says if Russia uses nuke the
U.S will no longer have secret weapons
they will all with intent be seen by the
world that's the thing man you know what
is that thing you talk walking plasma or
something talking plasma yeah it's where
they take a multiple laser beams focus
them into a point in the sky or wherever
and create a ball of plasma that they
can move around really fast they think
they're UFOs on radar they're like how
could a craft move that it's a lasers
and uh they can transmit sound through
that into the I think that when we're
talking about like silicon-based life
and carbon-based life that they're going
to create light beings that are
basically talking plasma and you think
they're real people well my point is
just the weapons they have you don't
know about you think it's like oh
they're gonna use nukes bro that was 80
years ago yeah and there's like one
story on talking plasma I've ever seen
you try and look up this is just like
easy technology that they've been
working on I would imagine
lethal strain says isn't directive 51
designed to build upon a designated
Survivor situation basically the idea is
if the government collapses there's a
protocol for restarting it but it's just
ridiculous and it can be abused that's
that's it
JJ says Guardians of a Looking Glass got
it right research it American Special
Forces has been teeing to reach out
trying to reach out is that what you're
saying hmm
Nathan Hillson says late fact check for
Ian from a fan pig farmer piglets are
only euthanized for terminal conditions
where piglets are where piglets are
suffering dead pigs means less money and
the farm hands dislike doing it I saw
some undercover footage of a guy working
in the [ __ ] pig farm just
indiscriminately taking it out how do
you know it's indiscriminate
uh it was just a baby pig grabbed it by
the back leg and started smacking its
head on the concrete maybe that's not
the way you euthanize something I don't
know maybe it is I don't know well then
that's the best practice if that's how
you euthanize pigs have you ever seen
someone like I don't know shoot a deer
um like we're gonna kill it need it we
put in meat grinders you know I mean
you're gonna smash its head with a rock
to death like there's a way to kill
something without causing it in insane
pain like the pig was squealing here's
my point here's my point that may be I
kind of feel like it's probably not I'm
just saying if you don't know well you
need to watch out for probably exactly
and for someone to say that they know
what all Pig farmers do that's also you
don't know you haven't seen what I've
seen and I haven't seen what you've seen
but I'm telling you I've seen video of
guy beating the pig to death by Smashing
It On The Ground whether you want to
call it euthanasia or not I don't know
have you ever seen how they actually
kill cows like have you seen the code
how they do the kosher no no the kosher
cow killing oh like Halal yeah is that
what it is that they put in this big
machine that spins it upside down and
they slit its throat yeah like none of
it is nice for the animal but we kill
animals and eat them you know I don't
know I mean it sounds bad but that's the
problem I don't trust these people
they'll film someone doing something and
then they'll be like look how bad that
was and you'll realize that's like
they're mandated to do it or something
I'm not saying that they are I'm saying
for all I know the FDA has been like we
don't allow external tool use for you
know euthanizing terminal pigs and so
they're forceded by the government then
they post a video you get mad and
coughing to be banned and you get this
propaganda BS you know what I mean well
I didn't call for anybody to be bad no I
mean I'm speaking rhetorically like they
put out these videos to shock you and
then what you don't realize is even the
farmers are like man it's really dumb
they force us to do these regulations
true it could have been shocked could it
was like Peter content I think it could
have been a guy staging it so they could
try and get money from you you never
know yeah I lived on a pig farm and most
Farmers love all the animals was it
industrial industrial this was one of
those industrial agriculture they're in
pig pens all tightly together like stuff
coming out of their eyes you know big
fat
all right
what is this uh diogenes how do you
pronounce that diogenes diogenes the dog
says I think you're right Tim prediction
tidal wave Hits DC before election and
it's blamed on Putin's sub that just put
to see
yo that would be insane if that happened
I'm gonna go ahead and say I really
don't think so
and they're talking about the
nuclear-capable sub they were just
talking about two or three days yeah
yeah the tsunami bomb
that's a cool phrase right tsunami bomb
it's also I think it's a punk band right
it sounds like it is
George D says rumors olensky zelenski is
planning false flag dirty bomb
I just go and assume like it's all false
Flags like all war now is like Russia's
attacking itself and Ukraine's attacking
itself and then blaming each other well
look at what happened in Syria with the
chemical weapons attack that you know
allegedly Assad was committing but a
number of investigative journalists
including ones from the BBC came and
investigated and said was a false flag
operation and then Donald Trump
responded by bombing Syria in response
to it let me take that a step further
the U.N actually sent their opcw inside
they put out a report and it was only
through Wikileaks you know while Assange
was basically at the embassy where they
published the emails that proved that
there was no chemical attack there that
those people basically did not put that
in their report and their report was
edited to make it seem like first of all
a chemical attack in Duma there's no
evidence any attack happened in Duma
just want to put that out there Austin
Unruh says question is a question is
what the military what is the military
going to do when they aren't keeping
their pay up with inflation and are
being told to go on food stamps that
that's happening right now actually
all right ill sentiment says hey Tim
Caster I've been watching since 2020 and
I'm currently a 20 year old gen Z I want
you to know gen Z has those who are
still reasonable glad to hear it that's
good news actually gen Z is slightly
more conservative than Millennials so we
get that
for whatever reason if anyone wants to
look into this pig thing I got a Daily
Mail article horrifying undercover
footage shows pig farmer workers
slamming piglets in a concrete floor
you'll be able to find it through this
video maybe we'll show it on the after
show because it is brutal jaspa pajak
says in Revelation 9 6 people will seek
death but will not find it they will
long to die but death will elude them
what if the transhumanists achieve what
they want but their hubris Dooms them to
a living nightmare yeah play uh play
Horizon what's the new one forbidden
West
have you not you're not have you not
played that game I have to listen I play
games that are five or ten years old I
rarely jump on some unless it's like the
new Mortal Kombat if you're talking
about transhumanism you got to play that
game all right yeah so I'll just spoil
it because the game's old anyway but
basically the bad guys are they can fly
they have force fields they're
Invincible they don't age or die and
it's a bunch of people who left earth
when a disaster struck long story short
and then they just achieved all of this
you know immortality they uploaded their
minds to an AI but then saw it was bad
and so they tried shutting it down make
enraging the AI who then broke out and
tries to kill him and chases them to
Earth and stuff like that so spoiler
spoil the game for everybody if you
haven't already played it too late
Horizon zero Dawn and Horizon forbidden
West are amazing games with great
stories you should check them out man
these post-apocalyptic games are so sad
basically in the first game which is
it's like seven how long has it been
seven years something like that eight
years it's uh this military uh
contractor military uh company
build self-replicating tanks basically
that can absorb organic matter to start
replicating and then eventually he can't
shut them off and so they start doing
the math and they're like these things
are going to completely just wipe out
all organic compounds on the planet and
then and then shut down so what do we do
so what you learn in the new game is
there's two scenarios one escape the
other build terraforming centers all
over the world underground so that once
the machines run out of organic matter
and Earth is a Barren Rock the
terraforming begins and starts creating
robots that emulate the life to create
the ecosystem and then humans are cloned
and then released
it's crazy gay man
it's cool though in the in the new game
you like find records from when people
were fighting against the robots and you
just I love post-apocalyptic games
because they're so what's the right word
sad is it the right word but is that
kind of said you know
all right ASAP mimic says Alina Hutchins
husband reached a settlement with Alec
Baldwin to drop the civil suit so he can
be an executive producer is that is that
very weird true to be an executive
producer yeah so he's going to be a
producer and the movie's going forward
yeah really they're going to be making
the movie still and he's going to be a
producer on it yep that's
what really
okay I guess huh
Commander Pluto says if you live to 100
the queen would send you a personal
birthday card congratulating you oh
that's nice the king you mean
the queen The Queen Is Dead long live
the king well we don't know if the king
will oh the queen queen would send you
but I mean what about the people that
turned 100 last week did the king send
him anything I don't know Bishop Riley
says look up Stellaris
what is that game it's like uh kind of
like it's real time strategy kind of
like Civilization but it's real-time
strategy space Sim Colony you know
colonizer you know the first thing I
thought of when when drones got released
now we're I was like these are going to
be used for war instantly that when the
parrot drone came out and DJ has
happened at these drones it's like it's
instant use in Warfare It's the eye of
kill Rod you know the eye of killer no
you don't you guys don't no no everybody
listening knows in Warcraft 2 I believe
it was the uh The Horde uh I think the
ogre Mages could create the eye of
killrog so in Warcraft it's like this
top down strategy you know you're
building the barracks the eye of Kill
Rock has no attack power but it can move
around and you can see with it so it's
the drum you fly it around it can die
whatever it's not that expensive but you
know it can reveal the map to you
detects invisibility too oh and you know
these people with those invisibility
cloaks are going to be detectable by
like infrared and stuff high-tech even
starlink and blackjack they're talking
about basically full-on surveillance
through Nano sensors and not traditional
video equipment so testing vibration
rather than
red light density things like that yes
Ghostface says I'll keep eating and
enjoying meat while telling Bill Gates
to go pound sand
you know we should uh we should do a
sketch or something we're working on a
uh a political cartoon channel on
YouTube we should just do a video where
Bill Gates goes around enforcing all the
things he's trying to do you got to be
Bill Gates we've got to get prosthetic
some makeup oh but so like Bill Gates
come someone's house and then and then
it's like you know the wife answers the
door and she's like Bill Gates is like
out of my way and then he walks in the
kitchen and just like throws all of
their food off the table and splatters
on the wall and they're like and then he
like he leaves then he goes door to door
doing the same thing
We're Gonna Save the Planet one person
at a time
I don't are you news guards certified I
think it's funny because like I I do
that voice but he actually does kind of
talk like that I know
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
after that meat pick sorry I'm now
pro-war
yo that mutton looked good I wanna I
wanna I wanna have some lamb I'm hungry
yeah thanks yeah I'm not giving up meat
I ate bacon last night still think about
that piglet video but man I keep eating
the bacon no step on snack says good God
Ian how did you get black pilled so bad
and that was in reference to when you
said the rich people will develop
develop a taste for a human and then
want to oh yeah uh geez how do I get
black filled I think when I learned
about the military industrial in 2006
and seven I felt very alone when I got
red pilled and when you're red pilled
and alone the red gets very saturated
and then becomes dark dark red oh you
could consider that black Eric Jenkins
had a Super Chat basically as uh similar
to the joke that I was bringing up plot
twist they already perfected anti-aging
treatments they just can't reveal them
until they call them asses all the
acceleration towards world war three is
Biden Pelosi types tired of having more
wrinkles on their face than brain
Nancy's like I just want to be pretty
fun again just blow them all up get put
into them
and then it's going to be like the nukes
go off as soon as the first nuke is
fired they put her in the Genesis
chamber and then she comes out she's
like 24. it's like I'm young again
all right Austin rice says Luke you rag
on Roundup glyphosate a lot as a farmer
from Nebraska what you're what are your
what your thoughts are on the AG sector
as a whole in my experience producers
are just using chemicals as needed to
cut down on Weeds to maximize yield
absolutely I mean there's benefits and
there's negative things especially when
it comes to uh fertilizer especially
when it comes to chemicals and
especially when it comes to Big
agricultural farming I think the biggest
problem right now is mono cropping us I
think the subsidies that are paying for
corn and soy in the way it's been
developed in the way that Monsanto now
Bayer has kind of uh cornered the market
for their own personal benefit where
they have uh made a patent on the seeds
is a huge problem and these monocrops
are leading to nutrient deficient foods
that are becoming less and less
nutritious so uh there's there's a lot
of things in play here it's not just
glycephate it's it's a lot of different
things I know some people you know make
a living off of big big farming I know
there's a lot of big money a lot of
taxes a lot of subsidies but in
retrospect we I think we do have to
consider the long-term kind of bigger
consequences to the world and everyone
else is Halloween on a Monday I think so
yes it looks like it so uh we're gonna
have yeah we're gonna have a show where
everyone has to dress up oh yeah yeah
cyberus says Tim in honor of impending
world war three you should be Tim ghoul
for Halloween a fun little Fallout joke
plus it'd be funny to hear the voice for
a bit what are the ghouls talk like that
dog like this yeah their vocal cords are
fries hey everybody Welcome to Tim guest
IRL
says graphene is the next asbestos
nanotubes have already shown to cause
mechanical damage to cells that's crazy
I think I saw something like that Ian's
gonna be 80. and he's gonna they're
gonna accidentally publish his obituary
and he's gonna be like I'm not he's
gonna read it and it's gonna be like Ian
Crossland purveyor of graphene Merchant
of death he's gonna be like whatever
that's like no Alfred Nobel
dynamite and then they name the Nobel
Peace Prize after him yep and then uh
well no no so they publish his obituary
calling him The Merchant of death yeah
and then he was like ah is that what I
am so then he made the Nobel Prize yeah
geez I talk I mean graphene is an
industrial building materials is top top
notch but I mean there's going to be a
whole slew of problems with this stuff
we all gotta be constantly vigilant
Noah Zork says PVC is good plastic it
drains your toilet yes it's polyvinyl
chloride and you can also skate on it it
is a material used by a lot of people
for uh various skate skating
yeah you can grind and slide on it PVC I
like PVC smooth but it breaks easily
when we built we would build ramps on
the cheap we would go with PVC because
it's really easy to to drill in and uh
you don't need a lot of wax for it but
they break so
it's always good to get metal or just do
concrete if you can afford it but that's
Philip Mangione says so I realized
something AI believes itself as the
Antichrist and is already loose read
Limelight lyrics as the devil speaking
to you AI equals Antichrist oh what if
that was it
could be AI is the Antichrist I get that
a lot a lot of people say that the AI is
going to be the big Takeover in the
Antichrist but then again you'd have to
be religious to believe that in the
first place which I am not yeah there
could be a lot of different antichrists
all working together or working against
each other well I get people telling me
the musker nuts is the Antichrist as
well and I don't buy into that
necessarily either musker nuts you know
Elon
um the musker nuts musker nuts
let's grab some more forced name change
says talking plasma equals musical Tesla
coils
technically you ever see those yeah when
they play the sounds of them that's
really cool they play songs
Daryl Lyon says if Poseidon is capable
of 100 megatons surface detonation at
Annapolis Coast Hits DC with Thermal
Zone and 1000 rad Fallout covers the
entire Northeast look at nuke map
cool cool
Andrew L says Tim I subbed to the site
before you added parallel economy how
can I switch my payments from PayPal it
should uh I think we're working on
something to make it go automatically so
I don't know
um email what is it members at
timcast.com the issue the issue is
signing up from PayPal does not mean one
thing and there's there's a couple
different ways depending on what you
what you do with PayPal it changes how
it interacts with us so email members of
timcast.com with any questions and we'll
help get that sorted but I do want to
stress if you become a member at
timcast.com you're not just supporting
us you're supporting parallel economy
which was co-founded by Dan bongino it
is a censorship resistant Financial
processor so we want to utilize them
because it's safer but it also supports
the parallel economy itself so update
from timcast.com the today's cast Castle
has been re-uploaded it may have been
temporary issue but hopefully that'll
fix it was it not working I think it
wasn't yeah it was like a momentary
glitch on rumble's end hopefully it
works now well all right then
Andy ugaldi says can you expand a little
bit on what would come after a tactical
nuke in Ukraine and no NATO response
what will life look like in that
scenario ah yes Ukrainian soldiers many
of them would lay down their arms and
flee for one of two reasons the first is
that they're scared of getting nuked
because there's no real way to fight
back against that level of power
the other reason is that many of these
people will say my wife and children are
in Kiev and that was hit by a tactical
nuke if it is if they hit a military
Target they hit a military Target
they'll move on if they hit a city
you're gonna get a bunch of fighting age
men being like I have to go home get out
of my way and they'll abandon trying to
find their families many of them won't
but many of them will and it will I
think that it will just destroy morale
for the Ukrainian Fighters because they
have no means of countering nuclear
artillery tactical nukes or heaven
forbid full-scale nuclear weapons I
think if Putin does that he wins the war
overnight I mean NATO may get involved
and be like we're going in with
Conventional Weapons now to support
Ukraine but it would destroy the
Ukrainian psyche the problem with Russia
winning or any kind of armistice is
it'll the conflict will continue on for
two decades after this if Russia takes
eastern Ukraine it's going to be 20
years of sub subterfuge like uh tactical
you know things blowing up power plants
unless we find actual diplomatic resolve
between the two Nations or at least the
taunt and I've been saying from the
beginning this conflict could last a
hundred years yeah and it very much
could all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kind
like button please smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this share with your friends be the
notification that YouTube isn't and head
over to timcast.com we're gonna have a
very very spicy uncensored after hours
show coming up at about 11 p.m you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Jason do
you want to shout anything out yeah
check me out on rockfin Rumble we're on
YouTube kinda and I'm gonna be doing a
four day a week live show 8 AM to 10 p.m
exclusively with red voice media coming
up in the next couple weeks I'm pumped
yeah everyone in the comment section is
like Luke and barmouth again what
together again for the very first time
yeah so yeah thanks for coming it's
awesome Henry Kissinger also came out
with some very interesting comments
today I talked about that on my YouTube
channel youtube.com forward slash we are
change and I did a separate video
talking about all the hard times ahead
of us how to prepare on Luke
uncensored.com hope to see you there
Jason you said your show 8 A.M is it P.M
to 10 p.m no it's gonna be 8 A.M
until 10 a.m okay but I go live almost
every day several times a day and I'm
going to keep doing that as well on top
of the show really I just try to keep up
on topics that aren't really in the
mainstream media I do a lot of
watch-alongs and a lot of document
breakdowns topics like rocket dine and
uh we talked about the movie nope
what other things did we talk about
terrorism movement Foundation yeah well
let's let's we'll save some of this
goodness for the after show I'm Ian
Crossland see you later
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in this evening I very much appreciate
it I'm training my replacement at the
moment I don't know uh if we were gonna
talk about this before tonight but I
mentioned it on pop culture crisis I'm
officially leaving timcast effective
Friday I'm training the guy who's taking
over for me you guys are gonna love him
he's fantastic you guys can follow me on
Twitter and minds.com at sour patchlitz
as well as sarahpatch lids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys